and we
are
live what's up everybody it is ibontis
here hosting the last word tonight with
my co-host mr tag guy travis cognito is
out at pax east so he is
busy in the other gaming sphere actually
talking to real people shaking hands
taking pictures he's doing what he loves
he's out there mingling networking and i
know he's having a blast but he could
not be here tonight because he was not
going to make it back to his hotel and
probably won't be back till the show's
over and long beyond that so we have to
hold down the fort tonight but before we
get going of anything else travis what
are you been up to this week man
it's been a it's been an interesting
week um one of my reviews i wrote a
couple weeks ago came out on monday to
thunderous applause and by applause i
mean booze uh
uh postal for which you can read on
ign.com and then uh i'm nearing
completion of another review for a game
that's going to come out early may uh
called truck to yomi
which i can't really talk about yet but
uh
i'm i'm deep into that review so just
keeping the content grinding through and
trying to play some destiny when i have
time so that's what's going on
kind of like a 2d goes to sushima felish
is that
um i wouldn't describe it as a ghost of
tsushima now i would say it's
it's more like um
it's like if a 2d hack and slash game
was trying to
make you feel like you were inside a
1920s 1930s black and white samurai
movie okay like it's very different
stylistically it's got more kind of
focus on like cinematic sort of feel so
um interesting game though it's on my
radar so i'll be curious when i know you
can't say anything yet but that's very
exciting um as for me
i dodged jury duty yesterday which i
would have been in today possibly
tomorrow possibly on monday like they go
in and they're like yeah this case could
take like three days
it was gonna be for a felony charge so
i'm like oh dear
uh but they it was absolute chaos and
honestly
i like it's it's a weird description if
you're curious about it but it was
with kovid trials have been very weird
and hard to do i know for the courts and
everything just due to trying to get
people together and then select juries
and stuff so they're starting to do a
little bit more
this one was bizarre so normally a jury
is like 12 people it always is
but there was a hundred people
called
and they had them spread out in this
like big room so it's like you know
every third seat was a numbered person
you had a row between so they were all
spread out for coven spacing and then
they went through and did this entire
process but the worst part was that
process didn't start until 11
30 or 15 and i got there at eight we sat
there for like three hours waiting for
the judge to show up
she said she got called to something
else i have no idea what it was we
didn't get any details
by the time we got done i did we didn't
know who was selected for the jury until
four o'clock in the afternoon and i got
there at eight
so it takes the process of like going
through and doing like the jury section
questions from the prosecutor and the
defense and they're asking questions but
they're asking them to a hundred
different people
so it's chaos and then people are in the
back of the room so the court reporter
can't hear him so there's some person
trying to walk the mic around this
ridiculous row of chairs and everything
um and you know just some of the
questions were like i can tell you guys
it was for aggravated assault with a
deadly weapon that was going to be the
charge
in the state where i live
the range of punishment is probation
to life
for that
that is the range of punishment
so
that's
that's probably the one that may have
gotten me out
because they're like can can you
in your right mind consider the full
range of punishment and i'm just going
to leave that question with you guys
because that one got a whole lot of
discussion around the room amongst some
other things but that was the one that
got some discussion anyway
thankfully i did not get picked um so i
was able to do all of the things that
happened today thank goodness
uh outriders got the world slayer
um
basically launch preview today so i know
you covered that forgot to mention that
yeah you covered that for ign i covered
it on my channel so world slayer is
going to be launching on june 30th same
day as actually monster hunter sun break
which is kind of surprising
um but yeah that one's gonna have full
expansion new levels like paragon levels
kind of like diablo for leveling up
looks like it could be fun i mean i
enjoyed my time i know some people had
major issues but hopefully at this point
it's less of a technical issue and
hopefully some people have fun but i
think that's all i've got to say so
we've got a nice guest that's waiting
for us
uh but yeah my jury summons i'm just so
thankful i'm not sitting there today but
before we get into it let's get this
thing started
welcome to the last word episode number
195
bungie dropped the mother of all twabs
on us earlier today outriders is coming
back for its encore tour and nicholas
cage is in a movie about nicholas cage
with a lot to cover we have a man who is
ready to get down to brass tacks and
talk all things destiny maybe only
destiny but we'll also have some jokes
about that one he's a veteran gamer who
started with the 8-bit classic so
appreciation for platformers was
ingrained early on sports here shooters
there he dabbled in many games over the
years but then came destiny and this man
has not looked back a tight-knit heart
knows that like captain america
sometimes you really do have to punch
your way out of the situation but he
really is well versed in all the classes
because he does solo guides for each and
every one of them
all the time need to solo at nightfall
on any level including grand master this
man will get you through it
if you
if you can do something solo in the
franchise
franchise of destiny it's fair to say
that he has likely done all of it i have
to tip my hat to him though he has
enough time to put out solo guides on
some of the hardest content and 7 500
hours in the franchise to prove it
and
somehow juggle a life that has eight
kids in it my mind explodes just
thinking about it i'm not even sure this
man sleeps but when he does i'm guessing
it's an interruption that's not too far
away so let's welcome a man with so
little left to do in destiny he debates
on starting a new account just about
every season who became unshackled from
his previous clan which is fitting
because he plays all content solo anyway
and overall just an ultra nice guy the
one the only
live mondo how are you doing tonight sir
i am very good thank you very much
that was quite cool
i enjoyed that
well happy to have you man here i know
i've kind of chatted with you off and on
on twitter and youtube and stuff over
the years and somebody in the comments
is like did he just say eight kids
yeah so
um i don't
have any
i have two dogs
i don't know how you have 7 500 hours in
this franchise which is more than
i've got probably between either piece
of the game
managed to record guides and put out
content and you've got eight you've got
to tell me how you juggle all of that
because alone eight kids i don't know
how you sleep ever
so you gotta tell me how this balance
works
i'm i'm secretly an octopus i have eight
hands oh your wife must like that she
does
it means i can do the dashes
i can do the dashes
and change the kids at the same time
uh
no uh i play
during a time where the kids are down
and sleep and stuff and
i mean you've got to remember destiny's
been out since 2014 and
my three youngest were all born after
that no so i started off with you know
have plenty of time to play i still have
a decent amount of time to play now i've
got a very
supportive partner who uh
allows me to do this and there's in fact
my full set up in front of me she
actually bought me she's the one that
kitted all this out i didn't do any of
it myself oh wow nice
very supportive
but uh
yeah
i don't know
it doesn't take me as long as people
think to do all of this
so it's not like i'm setting you know
yeah some of it i am but
other ones i'm not sitting here for
hours and i wasn't i was trying to get
the run
it's just like oh let me get a quick
grand master real quick all right let me
make some breakfast for the kids we're
good just knock it out no big deal no no
the glass way was definitely not like
that because you have three attempts at
the glassways four hours
yeah three attempts is four hours
because it's so about an hour and twenty
you know and twenty five minutes per run
and
the monday night
i'd done three runs and got to the same
y run and the same why problem was like
i think i recognize you
did you not learn the last thing don't
come from over there i'll teleport past
all your shots right into your face
and then the next morning i got at first
run so nice
but yeah i saw you actually twitter you
got that just like right before reset so
five minutes before the surface went
down
unbelievable that's uh i was looking at
well yeah i was looking at the time
thinking please give me the time to
finish this this is such a good run
yeah
why do you do it
uh
i mean there's there's two there's a
funny answer
but the real answer is
i don't know i suppose it's like anybody
in any
walk of life you
you know i'm not i don't have this
predisposition to put myself through all
this
but it is the question
could i do that
and if i can do it
can i show someone how to do it can i
make someone's life easier with a guide
where i talk through
every single little piece of
information that got me killed or that i
noticed
as something to avoid or something to
take advantage of
and at the end of the day if i'm being
honest and you guys as content creators
and as uh
writers and reviewers
there's nothing better after you've made
a piece of content for somebody to say
that helped
yeah you know that that that informed my
decision that informed my loadout i
couldn't have done this without the run
or it helped to run
that's why i do it
no it's a good feeling knowing that
you've helped people that's what's the
joke answer yeah i was like what's the
other answer
the real answer is
uh money no
[Laughter]
i don't know where this money's coming
from but there's
money somewhere
no
that's the real answer
yeah no i mean that's
i'm of the answer is i must say to
masochist that's yeah that's the that's
the real joke answer
or the real honest answer depending on
what we're going for no i mean i've been
i kind of started my thing the same way
similar mentality of
nightfalls in destiny 1 same thing i
went through and was like hey some of my
friends dropped off so i ended up doing
stuff solo hey if i can do this
maybe i can do the same thing so i know
it's like honestly you and i sound very
similar in
what we've done i haven't done as much
solo stuff as you have more recently i
used to do it a lot more
i'll do more lost sector guides but yeah
like the higher level nightfalls and
stuff you make them look pretty easy man
so it is it is impressive work just to
knock out a glassway solo grandmaster
and just clutch it up right there five
minutes before a reset so that's really
really cool
you guys will know when you do something
like that
there's a different feeling after the
completion
it's not like oh cool i can just now get
that edited get it up
there's a there's a setback in the seat
going
yeah
yeah i'm happy with that one because i
still think it's the hardest grand
master
i think the other grand masters that can
compete with it are only hard because of
the acute burn
this was hard before the acute man oh
glassway yeah that's true yeah
and it's it's an endurance it's an
endurance test as well i mean it's
it's 23 minutes on average to get to the
boss so you're an hour at the boss
which is ridiculous for any strike
you know you can knock out two reads you
know almost
yeah anytime you're doing a solo gm
yeah that's a lot of patience to
it's a lot of focus the focus has got to
be there you can't make him you know no
i finally soloed my first gm i did arms
dealer it's like by far like the easiest
one but i mean i finally solo my first
gm
probably before reset as well actually i
think it was monday when i did mine
uh and totally she's the boss by the way
use the grenade method didn't mind but i
mean yeah it is one of those things
you'll get to a point where it's like
you'd start out and
if you just sneeze the wrong way it's
four bullets from the barrier colossus
or
you know look the wrong direction for a
rocket there's very very little margin
for error it is patience to learn and
practice to know
where you have a little bit of giving
yep it is it is experienced
you don't get that without i can't make
an omelet without breaking some eggs and
then
once you go in on it you know i guess my
question about why you do it is more of
the like
at least with solo grand masters like
nobody has to do those
no and in fact i would argue that
there's probably an extremely extremely
small pool of people who even want to
try
to be a grand master nightfall solo you
know what i mean so like if you're not
getting special rewards for it and
there's not a lot of people out there
trying to do it what drives you guys to
want to do that completely optional
kind of hurdle of doing something solo
because
i feel like i've got
whatever it is that can work that out
right well
other people can decide what that treat
is but i feel like whatever it is i'm
pretty good at working stuff like that
out and it and i think
if you see someone do it
and you watch a guide like that it can
inform you on what you would do
different and it can help teams get it
done and it's not so much a solo guide
for solo players
it's a guide on how the encounter works
and what's different in the grand master
and where's the best place
to be and you know where you're safe to
attack from and if you see one person
doing it a team can take advantage of
that
so what i get from it is
really the knowledge that i could be
helping people get through that
yeah you know that's why i started
youtube i didn't start it to become
you know people recognize me or know my
name or stuff i was talked into doing it
because for the whole of d1
that's what i was doing i was soloing
all the nightfall solo and reads
you know my buddies were like
you know you should start making guides
because you simplify everything for
people
and that's where it started i didn't
even watch youtube until d2 i'd never
seen a youtube video before i actually
started making youtube videos
well very nice
it's like honestly yeah it's like we
kind of
feel some similarities in there shout
out real quick to gaming forte with the
five dollar super chat bunch you put a
tombstone on the grave of my deer hunter
i didn't crutch zompies but this will
hurt most people not feeling the arbless
nerf at all i will get to that and
believe me the arbolous nerf doesn't
feel great to me either
i guess it is a bit of a multi-tool they
had to take one of them away but yeah
not a big fan of it anyway um
anything else you want to ask travis or
we have a giant twab to cover perhaps i
say let's jump into that twab man
there's enough meat on the bone for
a four-hour show yeah so we got as i
said in the intro the mother of all
twabs and a lot of this is from the
sandbox
um
designer chris proctor he was the one
who put most of this together
and the main pieces they go over that
handful of goals that they wanted to
cover from the team they made a lot of
changes to get in the air
glaives
those are actually getting a little bit
of a
rework i'm not sure they're going to be
the ultimate be all end all but again
they do are getting some love
flinch airborne accuracy those are huge
huge chunks i'm not gonna go into all of
the nuances of every single number but
there are some noticeable things to call
out especially that hunter nerf as well
is like one of them that people are
gonna be you know losing their mind over
on twitter for a little while oh yeah
one hit kills crucible special amo
they've got some interesting numbers and
graphs where they can actually show you
the data which is cool and then just
general stuff like exotics weapons and a
lot of other stuff
so the biggest thing
that they talk about is the main pieces
are the goals and some of the goals just
if they're going to go over some of the
high level pieces
are they want to introduce levels to
tune how levers to tune how players
build for airborne gunplay so they want
to make people say i want to play into a
being airborne
advantage that you're going to have to
lean into that a little more but it's
going to take a little more of your
build to
lean into that as opposed to just kind
of getting it with say one mod on a gun
uh they want to have players have an
ability to mitigate flinch so flinch is
one of those things a lot of people have
had issues with people's want are people
are going to be able to invest in flinch
resistance and depending on the type of
weapon depending on the subclass
depending on all the different pieces
you can lean very far into that if
that's your thing they want to reduce
the number of one-hit kills in pvp
special weapon they want to have the
primary gun play still shine a little
bit more really getting to like
one-on-one gunplay fights as opposed to
just the one-off bam snipers shotguns
fusions all of those things they still
see is quite high they made a very
substantial change to that and then just
common feedback on weapons like
legendaries that aren't really feeling
too great exotics that aren't being used
or a couple that are over performing and
it's just a huge pass on weapons going
into season 17 which is going to launch
in literally just about a month
so the first one is going to be glaives
they say glaives should
activate perks that trigger based on
melee damage or kills
they should not activate on perks that
trigger off powered melee kills picture
any of your
melee abilities that you have for your
character
melees should benefit from melee damage
buffs like worm god caress or winter's
guile they should not benefit from
weapon damage buffs or melees i'm sorry
should not benefit from weapon buffs
like rampage or kilkup or swatch buckler
but projectile should
so those are the main things they're
going for with glaives now they already
did some changes in season 16 but in
season 17
they are pushing the glaze deeper into
their roles as hard-hitting melee damage
near complete protection windshielded
and increasing projectile speed
so so i think very little people
surprised because impulse amplifier was
extremely popular on glaives they've
boosted the projectile speed
if you have a zero stat on range it's
going to go from a 30 to a 60
so it's going to double that meters per
second and then at 100 stat on range
it's going to go from 80 to 100 so the
range was 30 to 80 now it's 60 to 100
so it's going to be a much faster
projectile the energy drain on your
shield is going to be 30 slower
the melee damage versus pve enemies
except bosses and vehicles is going to
be 25 increased
and uh the glaive shield grants a 97.5
pve damage resistance pvp 75
um that surprised me actually that 95
surprised me
yeah that's that is a that is an
absolute metric ton of them i was
practically told that total resistance
yeah i mean you're taking two and a half
percent damage in pve if you pulled out
that shield so if you do play into a
glaive if you need unstoppables this
season
if you're running for right now i've
only got void and solar if you need that
type of shield i mean i even listened to
datto talking about his one master raid
video he was using on lubrez ruin for an
unstoppable and solar damage so he's
like he was actually using that for an
archetype this will make it much more
viable for those moments you're like i'm
going to die you pop the shield
you're likely going to survive most of
what comes at you travis i wanted to get
your thoughts on
our glades are just like are they a joke
to you now do you feel like these might
actually make them viable where are
glaives for you at this moment and does
this like appeal to you
slaves am i a joke to you
um
yeah i think uh
glades sort of came in hot and then a
lot of the momentum came out of them i
think partially because of the changes
that they made to seasonal mods which
they've kind of never done before i'm
not really sure why they did that i
thought seasonal mods were supposed to
be overpowered
but
uh yeah i do think that if they want
glaives to be useful they need to make
some sort of changes to it i think the
shield is good especially for pvp
uh obviously pve it's good too the
projectile change is probably the
biggest change that needed to happen
just because
the you know time to the velocity i
guess they call it time to reach the
enemy um is makes it basically
impossible to use in pvp uh and even in
pve it's annoying you know how many
characters can disappear and teleport
and do like twitch dodges and stuff like
that it just can really get irritating
so um yeah i think overall like
this may be an over correction
to uh mondo's point like i was surprised
at the 95
or whatever it was 97.5 97.5 yeah i was
surprised by that too but also
if you are using that shield you can't
really attack while you're using it so
i don't know if
i'm pretty sure you can fire the engine
like i think you can fire while you're
holding fire the energy bus while you're
holding it down while you're shielded
yeah god damn yeah that's right
right in front of unstoppables because
it's got unstoppable glaive yep it's
pretty good it's pretty good yeah so i
think they may have overcorrected then i
i think is my my first thoughts just
reading it so we'll see um but either
way they had to do something if they
want people to actually use glaives for
real and not just for memes so yeah
especially when as you said the mods did
get nerfed but if you take away the mods
this season that leaned into them pretty
heavily if you take most of malay next
season which we don't know what we're
gonna have yeah you would need something
to make them worthwhile so i'm happy to
see those what about you mondo anything
on those outside of obviously the damage
resistance we all think is pretty high
yeah uh i think i think mods i think
sorry i think glaives
i don't know i don't know how anybody
would think that they haven't been good
so far
if you take
yeah yeah a hundred percent if you take
now just to add to a bonuses point
some of the seasonal mods
do
increase the validity within pve
obviously the suppressant glaive
being the main one
but all the subclasses have so if you've
got that suppressant uh glaive all the
subclasses have melee killstart health
regeneration which works for the melee
on the glave
so if you just go through a whole heap
of enemies you come out of there
generating your health
and the speed that you can melee from as
well
i'm glad that the
velocity of the
energy blast has been changed because
you really have to lead an enemy with
that shot they've got to run into the
shot especially because as you've
already alluded to
they'll move i mean there's very little
enemies that stand there waving from 30
meters hey you know they're all on the
bike they're all gone the biggest change
and i know you haven't covered it yet
and i'm pretty sure you're going to come
to it next because it's right below it
exotics yeah we'll get the exotics yeah
that's that's gonna be that's gonna be
big
so yeah the exotics have all been buffed
to no surprise they've been a joke to a
lot of people because to take an exotic
slot you're one exotic slot it's got to
be potent and in my mind i'm still not
entirely sure some of these are going to
do it for some people because to
overpower things like arbalist for its
functionality or gal horn or
many other things that we're actually
going to talk about that got powerful
i'll still be curious if these like jump
into people's loadouts for more than a
meme but still
titan glaive will now gain
void overshield while inside the bubble
and helm of state 14 will also apply to
the bubble as it does for word of dawn
so it's smaller but you're going to get
most of the effects of the actual bubble
the overshield so being inside the
bubble is much less of a joke the
warlock glaive i think is the one we've
got to see the most in action because it
increases the speed and acceleration of
the healing term projectiles i mean if
it's like firing about rapid fire that'd
be cool but i don't know if they're
gonna quite take it to that level the
hunter glaive is they're going to this
is when you know something was not
strong enough when you read the
numerical values hunter glaive they
tripled the damage of the wave
detonation and increased the number of
enemies it can hit from four to eight
so yeah the hunter glaive was not good
and definitely not worth your time but
the fact that they tripled the damage
that's really substantial and then also
the number of chained enemies doubled so
yeah the hunter glave got a lot of love
i still don't know if one attack
is worth your exotic slot
i'll have to see but what do you guys
think careful damage could be good i
mean it could be like a super grenade
um i think the main thing here is
how much quick more quickly uh the the
special abilities charge to me that was
the big problem with these weapons is
that you know the juice wasn't worth the
squeeze when it came to
you know used to kill i think it was
like eight things before before you got
to it was like six and now it's down to
four i think as if that's the way that
six don't you four
yeah so i think that is huge
um but yeah with all the other changes
especially the ones that made to the
titan one which is the one i was trying
to use
uh you know making it work with saint 14
making it actually give you an
overshield so it's not like you're just
sitting in it for fun i think those are
both uh very big changes so i'm happy
with it we'll see we'll see if it's good
though yeah the tech the titan glaive
the this
you've used that travis right yeah
so
am i correct in saying that when you
fire down the bubble it can't be
destroyed
uh
i think it can be destroyed by damage
i'd well i i
i'm pretty sure i'm just you've used it
more than i have
because the titan wants the one i
haven't used that was the last one i got
so i haven't tested that one i'm pretty
sure the thing about it is it lasted 30
seconds
regardless
now that you've mentioned it i don't
know if i've ever seen it get destroyed
but i also was just like
kind of playing around with it random
activities yeah i was just like god you
have to kill a lot of things to even get
this to trigger and then it doesn't give
you any sort of benefit running inside
it and i was just like i'm just gonna
take this off so that would be an
interesting time that would be
interesting to experiment with like i
don't know if it's based off of your
resilience the way the actual ward of
dawn is
i've never been experimented that much i
did get that one like that was my first
one obviously because i played on my
titan the most but
if it's got the potential to last for a
very long time in certain encounters it
could be huge because you could do a
bubble and you could do it
massive
and getting the replenishable overshield
and the blinding effect
i mean you could literally put that over
an ad spawn door and just be like
we don't have to worry about those
yeah anything that comes over there is
all of a sudden you know i see the light
the warlock glaive
that is very interesting because i did
play with that
if you put that healing turret down now
you guys have done the the memory
missions for a sabbath mm-hmm
there's one where you go in and there's
like a massive whistle you've got to
take out it's like the
the memory protector i can't remember
what they're actually called
and i put one of them down and stood in
front of her and that healing turret was
healing me faster than she could damage
me
and they've increased it
and it lasts a lot longer than you would
think it does i think that lasts for
about
15-20 seconds
nice
yeah again that's kind of the debate
that i think i'll be curious to see is
is having a
multi
exactly like the fact that they gave it
triple damage is the numbers tell alone
but it's like again will you want to use
an exotic glaive is the functionality
enough to beat out other things and
that's just i think what we're gonna
have to see if it's barrier not overload
probably not if it's unstoppable
involved it might give you a little more
incentive to experiment depending on
what you're facing what your class is gm
if you're in a gm could it could end up
being very similar to the way people use
divinity you know someone have avoid
glaive on kill those four enemies now we
put a bubble up and everybody gets a
replenishable overshield and just charge
your shot back up now it does say to
void overshield while inside the bubble
that may be one of those that when you
pop out it's gone so that may be where
they're gonna balance that out
but the same 14 gives you an overshield
when you go inside that if it works the
way home 14 does it gives you and your
teammates an overshield to bring out of
the bubble okay and every time you go
back in it replenishes it so many people
leans into like if you're going to go
that way you want to run that exotic as
well if that's the case
yeah
they were so underwhelming they needed
to increase them somehow yeah so yeah
glaives getting some love both in damage
resistance projectile speed pretty much
lots of things that everybody was asking
for and the exotics get a buff so we
will have to see how they feel but
definitely feels like it will be worth
the test for sure second major change
flinch
a lot of people have issues with this a
lot of people are annoyed by it a lot of
people can't stand the fact that it
happens to them why is flinch even there
some people like other games if you get
hit you'd pop out of ads scope so it
varies depending on what game you're
playing what you're used to but flinch
is the thing depending on if you do
weapon testing at all
and
what they're doing is they have rebuilt
before i say this one shout out to
necromancer zale 10 super chat in your
opinion which exotic weapon got the best
buff when we get to those i promise you
we will tell you
i hate you don't don't you killed
marbles that's my real answer
serious uh thunderlord may be very low
than they hate travis
thunderlord may be very potent but
that's like a random off the cuff
because i know
uh machine guns got a puff but uh they
rebuilt the stability weapon stat to
grant flinch resistance in addition to
its other effects so with a maximum
flinch resistance of 10 to 25 depending
on the weapon archetype so if you have a
hundred stability on say an auto rifle
you get 25
flinch resistance
if you have a hundred stability on a
sniper rifle you get ten percent flinch
resistance
and then it goes in that it can pair
with other things because also they've
added to resilience which for the titans
um
oh yeah graviton lands in xeno we'll
definitely talk about those resilient
stat is now also going to give you
up to a 10 flinch resistance buff as
well titans already lean into it anyway
for the barricades so some of us right
now especially with void 3.0 may get
even a little extra benefit now 10 isn't
the biggest amount of flinch resistance
in the world but
they basically describe an idea of if
you stack most everything you can get
almost up to like 90 flinch resistance
so if you take 100 stability soros pulse
rifle with 10 resilience so tier 10 not
10 but actually like 100
no distractions on a primary weapon
which i really don't see using so that
one's like i guess if you're going for
extreme two unflinching pulse rifle mods
and behind a rally barricade you can
have 90 flinch resistance so if you want
to
not worry about flinch if you get shot
and you're like i don't care i'm still
gonna be a laser beam you can lean into
it which is one of the things like a big
theme about kind of a couple big chunks
of this weapon change is if there is
something you want to lean into now for
how your weapons feel you actually have
the ability to try and build into that
depending on your class your armor your
weapon and all of the pieces involved
um do you guys have any thoughts about
flinch is it something you
even care about that much either of you
guys travis you look like you're being
very pensive right now
yeah i do care about flinch i think it's
an important part of any um
game that has multiplayer and destiny
does have multiplayer because
it really only comes into account in
multiplayer like obviously in pve it
matters too but it's not like
i think people view flinch as something
that hurts them but the way i view it is
it's something that helps me because if
somebody's aiming on you with the sniper
rifle and you manage to get a shot on
them and they shoot you in the head
anyway it can be really frustrating for
you to be like how the heck was i
shooting somebody in the face and they
managed to like
you know counter snipe me when i was
sitting at him and so i agree i've had
that run through my head multiple times
i'm like yeah i just i just tagged you
how could you have got that shot off
yeah exactly that could be really
irritating so i view it as
something that has to be part of the
sandbox and um and they can actually be
helpful to you as a player if there is
flinch but i do think that
um
there should be a way to override it to
your point to the to bungie's point and
i think largely this entire swab was
about them making improvements to build
crafting you know and and the ways that
you can kind of like spec out your
character and so it's a very interesting
dynamic to me choosing well do i want my
character to have better recovery so
that my health can come back longer or
faster or do i want to
be able to take more damage and not have
to worry so much about dodging and
jumping in the air and that sort of
thing because i can just like counter
the flinch and then just like beat them
you know what i mean and so i like that
dynamic a ton it's a super tight
philosophy also not one i really share i
tend to be a titan that moves around a
lot like i'm always sliding and like you
know i'm i kind of have like a almost a
hunter kind of dance on my brain which
is probably something that i got from
playing uh so much halo
but
uh it is uh i think it's very cool that
they're doing this and i like that they
gave multiple ways for you to counter it
uh and and that sort of thing so
um i'll be interested to see i imagine
that this one's gonna have a ton of like
changes to it they're gonna have to like
fine-tune this thing down perfectly but
i love that they're adding it to
uh the one of the elements that you can
kind of build craft and i think
resilience is also the right one to add
it to because resilience has always felt
a little underwhelming so yeah
yeah i like all of this i think this is
a great change
mondo what about you man
i think
i agree with what's been said to a
degree
uh it's good that it
it's annoying
but it's
there's a reason for it
but i think what this is gonna do it's
it's great that you can
you know i i again i'm just repeating
this part of what's been said before
it's great that now you can bell craft
into this
because for people that
really go in for this especially in
crucible
it's just more things to look at now
it's a different build to try and get
you know
more more and
you know
i think what this is going to do i
wonder how this all works when you throw
into the mix high caliber rounds and
stuff
you know there are
uh perks that are built to flinch you
even more
so is that going to bring them to the
fore
i mean in pvp you might see somebody or
if you put high caliber rounds on a
scout rifle if somebody's sniping that
may be your play because if you're like
hey i can't seem to get this this guy's
hitting his shots no matter what but you
put high caliber rounds on it you can
get that
reticle to move enough that could be
something that actually gets into it so
there are some ones that can counter it
as you said which is good but it as you
said it also gives you the ability to
lean into it if that's your play style
the maid is one of the best
ranged kind of anti-sniper weapons
because it's like mid to long
you know if you're really good you can
go close but
mid to long problem with it was the
flinch
but because it's got high car intrinsic
you know it's not high caliber is you
know it knocks your head back
intrinsically if you can belt craft any
weapons like that where you cannot get
the flinch or or you can
not get the flinch but you know you can
dampen the flinch to a degree yeah
it is going to bring different weapons
into the sandbox that maybe people don't
see at this moment in time with but
i think that might be a separate stat
based on what i was reading in the the
12 because i think they're trying to
make a distinction between flinch which
is when you're getting shot versus
recoil which is when you're shooting and
i think what you're discussing is recoil
is recoil
but if you get short while aiming the
middle you're you're you're practically
bird watching straight away
the sight goes all over the place
yeah that was the issue with the maiden
if you can build craft into this with
the intrinsic perks that it actually has
that's what i'm saying it's going to
bring a lot of
this is very interesting for the stuff
that's not on the page the stuff that it
suggests that could happen
you know yeah no yeah that makes sense
yeah i think i think it's awesome we'll
see
see i will be very curious to see if
anybody makes like hey you know crazy
flinch build and actually shows
you know the weapon testers out there
are going to do the crazy stuff they're
going to go into private lobbies they're
going to be like this is your flinch
before this is your flinch this is you
before this this is you after like
sounds like a terrible commercial or
something but
yeah this is your brain on drugs no but
it actually it is
that is one of those things they're
going to do the test and then uh reveal
that the flinch stat actually does
nothing does not affect your if that
will be what it is i mean i feel like
that's what that's what happens like
half the time they do the test yeah they
very well could show that as well the
little reticle just looks like it's the
same i guess good to know so
so the next big chunk and this is
probably one of the biggest with regards
to numbers that i'm not going to go as
deep into but i got to give you a bit of
an idea is airborne effectiveness
before getting into build crafting we
made a fundamental change the modifiers
applied while airborne your primary
weapons will have less randomness in
projectile accuracy in most cases you
have an accuracy cone somewhere in that
cone your bullet's bound to go
you'll have less aim assist instead so
if you're in the air you're going to
have less aim assist less you know
magnetism towards the head which even
could still be the wrong term but on the
other side you're going to have less
randomness so it's going to
make you basically have to aim is the
biggest thing if you're airborne you are
going to have to manage your aiming the
game is going to give you the least
amount of help in a lot of cases and
they've got levels of stats now this is
a new stat that's going to be on weapons
during season 17 it's going to be hidden
from the game screen but in season 18
they do mention several previously
hidden stats which i'm assuming this new
one called airborne effectiveness you've
got aim assist recoil direction
um probably one more that i'm missing
those that you will go look in the api
and see on sites like d2 gunsmith and
other places those are actually look
like they're gonna be on the weapon
screen now which is good because with so
much information that we get in here if
you hide all of this stuff from a player
it's just a new player is going to be
already lost anyway you don't need to
hide it then we need more information
for the player to be able to see so this
is a good thing
but you've got basically different
levels of this airborne stat
they say with no investment 0 to 30 a
character will have a small accuracy
penalty
but will have significantly lower aim
assist 31 to 50 around the same in-air
accuracy as they would with icarus but
with still noticeably lower aim assist
so you've got to make the shots but if
you're accurate you're accurate uh with
substantial investment 51 to 70 a
character will have better accuracy than
normal weapons with icarus uh with few
misses due to randomness but still
reduced aim assist 71 to 99 they will
have no airborne accuracy penalty with
very slightly less aim assist and then
if you get to full 100 aim assist or
airborne stat you will have no airborne
accuracy penalty and you will have the
same assist as you would standing on the
ground so if you lean into it heavily
really heavily you can basically be just
as effective if you are good as you are
on the ground
um so that being said the stat has been
hand tuned for all exotic weapons
everything that shipped in season 16 and
will be coming in 17 and everything that
shipped that's ever shipped as trials or
nightfall loot older legendaries because
they can't get to them all kind of have
random or not random they have set
archetype values that are just general
per archetype class
they go into a lot more detail on a lot
of this stuff with regards to aim assist
cones and penalties for
special weapons they basically say are
going to be much
less viable airborne that's one of the
main things they state is primary
weapons are one thing they're trying to
get us to lean into
and you're not gonna have as much of a
penalty special weapons
much harder to manage if you're airborne
for example
so basically you'll notice you've got
accuracy cone penalties and then you've
also got your
aim assist and all that stuff it gets
into a lot of the nuance um but most
weapons are going to have like a base
stat value for legendary weapons like
hand cannons somewhere between 0 and 25
sidearm 0 to 30. uh some like snipers
zero to five shotguns zero to five
fusions zero to ten
uh breach loaders zero to five so if you
go airborne these base stat values for
especially a lot of the special weapons
are going to be very low
uh scout rifles if you're airborne a
little bit lower that's zero to 20
submachine guns zero to 30.
so you can kind of get the feel of
what's gonna help you and what's not
going to
there are some legendary weapons
that are going to have like higher tiers
of legendary weapons like trials raids
nightfall will typically fall in the
upper echelon some exotics as well sweet
business 27
sunshot 27 rat king 30 huckleberry 33
travelers chosen 35 sky burners oath
literally built to float in the air 35
chaperone one
if you want to hit your shot with
chaperone in the air you're definitely
going to have to make sure you're the
one doing ace of spades 14. they say
it's plenty strong it doesn't need any
extra help thunderlord 26 random stuff
like that
so i mean you can go through and look
through all these numbers um subclasses
still will give some benefits to the
airborne effectiveness stat
heat rises is going to give you plus 70.
so if you're running heat rises you are
nearly going to be like you're standing
on the ground because that's going to
cover most of the downfall that you're
going to have so warlocks if you're
playing the heat rises build you're
still probably going to be feeling
pretty comfortable up there
tempered metal i don't even remember who
that's specifically for
i keep reading it and the whisper of
hedron stasis fragment is plus 20 after
freezing at target the tempered metal
one is plus 20 after getting a solar
weapon kill
so there's a couple subclass abilities
that will help you be more effective
airborne
now there's a lot of exotic armor that
is going to benefit you for being
airborne but there is one
that will hurt you when you are airborne
and this is the giant
issue on twitter and it is stompy's
stomp piece is going to give you a minus
50 to your airborne effectiveness that
for all weapon types
so whether it's the applaud button
hey
round of applause
um
i mean cool guys been talking about if
you listen to him on some of his stuff i
know he's been saying it's coming for a
while a lot of people have
and they get to the point with stompies
because if you look at the weapo the
exotic usage they actually had a graph
for it
stompings are used by about 40 45
percent of hunters
in pvp
if the bunchy doesn't like anything to
have that much use and if they're going
to give you the mobility now they're
saying you're going to be less accurate
in the air
if you want to be airborne you might
have to figure out another way to manage
it things like oath keepers help for
bows making your strict sleeves is 50 to
sidearms a fitting aspect is just 10 for
all which is weird because it's also
used about as much so that's an
interesting one
uh random one wings of sacred dawn plus
50 to all
so again warlocks can basically lean
warlocks with wings of sacred dawn and
then uh heat rises
you're good to go you're gonna be
floating sniper gods i don't think
that's gonna change
but the hunters with the minus 50 on
zombies they're gonna feel it but that's
the one every every hunter is jumping
and shooting you from above in the air
and apparently that was something they
wanted to crap on so i want that was one
of the biggest things that i saw for
twitter especially a lot of the exotics
will get like faux tracer plus 20 to
everything
hallow fireheart for titans plus 20 to
everything
uh lion rampants hip fire only which is
kind of weird but interesting yeah
peregrine greaves already airborne with
the shoulder charges 20 to everything
astrocyte verse 30 i have another world
15 so you'd have to look through and see
which exotic and this is another thing
like if this is not told to you in game
it needs to be because if you pull it
back to your rig and you're like cool
but if you jump in the air now your auto
rifle's a little better because you're
wearing this
exotic it needs to tell us somewhere in
game so i do hope they start commuting
more of this
in-game knowledge
anything that you guys see in here or do
you have any thoughts about the stompies
are you happy since we're all titans
yeah i mean
good about the stompies that's all i
have to say about it i mean it's just
i have nothing against it and i i
respect the warlock jumping game but it
was a it was like oversized and its
influence in pvp it was a lot of
people's entire strategy and
um since it's so much harder for
somebody to shoot you when they're on
the ground especially when you're you
know messing with the radar and getting
caught up in pieces of the environment
up there and you know just bouncing up
and down like a bunny and are just
harder to shoot it should be harder for
you to shoot back like it just it just
should i you know i don't i don't know
how else to put it so
um this this patch makes sense to me
this is another one where i assume that
they're gonna have to pull it back a
little bit i don't think it's going to
go it feels reminded really because
there's no other exotic that's a
negative at all and it's a negative 50.
it's like they're just like we just want
to crap on stompies and see what else
you guys use for a little while this is
one of those you said this is a standout
nail we're going to smash it through the
board
we're going to see what else you guys
use then maybe bring it back up a little
bit i agree with that that feels like a
heavy hit to see what else gets used and
then see how it feels from there some
people are saying that it does take away
the identity of this is your airborne
mobility exotic like literally lion
rampant is similar kind of but you don't
use it in pvp the same way
yeah it's not used in pvp the same way
it does it also titans are extremely
easy to hit when they're in the air i
would say the same is true of warlocks
hunters just the way that their their
jump moves yeah it's it's the best pvp
jump because it it you know bounces it
makes it harder for you to hit you're
constantly moving even in the jump
you're constantly moving and changing
directions and all that stuff and if you
can fire at an enemy with like aim
assist and stability on your gun and
they're having to like constantly it
just it just makes it uh really really
hard to counter in a lot of situations
so
um yeah i just think you know the stats
kind of say it all right like
it's being used by so many hunters in
pvp and i think there's a reason for it
and uh you know we
i'm i'm this is coming from a guy who
was sad to see what's going on with
chaperone as a as a chaperone uh player
myself but uh i i also agree with that
change i mean chaperone should be
difficult to aim in air because it can
one shot somebody if you get a head shot
so
um yeah i think all around all the stuff
they're doing with
kind of building out uh airborne
mechanics i think that's right on the
money bringing it forward and making it
visible to players is great and adding
it as something that you can build for
is great um but i think if you if you
create a path for people to build make
airborne builds that gives stompies even
more power because it means that you can
build even more into that and make
yourself just like a a bouncing god and
i i think stompy's had to go for this to
happen so yeah um yeah i mean i know
it's gonna sound like i'm just being a
titan chill but like good stompy's
needed to go man it just needed to go
yeah i mean that's one of those things
about the charts you see him
i mean right now laura lee splendor is
one of the titan ones that's very busy
or like very high in use right now and
even dmg said that one's like
that's getting ready to get nailed too
so we know that one's coming we're
luckyfitting aspect though that one's
got about 35 usage that is a very
popular one and that didn't get hit
nearly as hard because that's a plus 10
it's not major but it's also not
negative even though a lot of people are
using it's not the same in mobility it's
not airborne built but it is
you know kind of there's high usage
exotics that are not going to get hit
quite as much it seems so i as you said
i think you're right that
it probably won't be as bad but they
probably do want to see what the hunters
do if we knock this thing into the
ground that's one of their ways to do it
sometimes they nerf or buff something so
much they want to see what the shift in
the met is what do you think mundo you
got any thoughts on any exciting or
terrifying moments here
well
if we talk about the stormy thing versus
the titan helmet just that was right off
the bat and even the affiliate aspects
the ephedian aspects add
they increased something for the warlock
the stompies
changed something for the warlock
because
years ago i watched the video with miss
5000 watts where she before icarus was a
thing in the game
and because it wasn't to start with
and she was saying the reason why they
took it out is because
vertical combat
is the last thing on you know it's it's
the hardest thing to combat for the
average player the normal players
because
you look forward you don't look up all
the time you see that thing coming in
front of you that red marker on your
reader and the la the first thing you'll
check is in front yep and by that time
they've come out of the clouds with a
shotgun or whatever
i think the reason why affiliate aspects
add
obviously they grant a couple of things
for the warlock but
stone piece have been around forever
and they can
if you can use them if you're good with
them and they've been around for that
long that most hunters that use them
they're used to using them yeah
they can come out so far out the sky
there's been plenty of times off when
there's a guy around here somewhere
where is he and then i've died and this
guy is still being five meters above me
you know when i've died so
but again like like i said for the last
change
they spoke about uh
the
improved air assault uh
perk
i mean perks are gonna come into this as
well it's all about what they're
basically doing is and i think we're all
aware of this
the shift in the sandbox is not just to
you know clarify what all these things
are going to do but all because there
was some of the exotics that increased
stuff that i didn't realize did increase
stuff
yeah four tracer i didn't know that that
was completely out of left field for me
but it's just about changing the sandbox
in subtle ways like making people have
to bow towards a certain they want to
keep playing the way they want to play
they've got you know build a different
way
so i think travis said this before about
uh change is coming in the twab and then
you go out and you're like no this is no
different
all of this needs to be seen to be you
know we have to experience this to see
how big a change these things are
actually going to be and what's going to
replace them that aerosol filled me with
a little bit red when i seen that they
reworked it we'll see what that does as
well yeah
i mean it makes sense they this is the
time to add that back now that they're
building it out because before i think
the problem with it was
what was actually happening when you
were airborne was like a black box and
now that they're bringing it to light i
mean it makes sense they need to expand
that's that sandbox and isn't season 17
where we're supposed to get new crystal
maps
uh if we get one right one new crucible
map next season and then supposedly
season one and then season 18 is
supposed to be
i thought it was two old ones next
season and then new ones in 18 but maybe
i've got it wrong
i could too but one way yeah one we get
18 we get the rift mode back right or we
get d1 maps rift is supposed to be
somewhere they've said that but we get
two d1 maps i think in
18 or 17 again i have it backwards and
then the other season whichever way it
is
is one brand new map
exactly whatever way they'll bring
bringing and that's i think this
this has got a massive eye on whatever
they're going to be doing with crucible
and 17. yep
so yeah they have one example i have a
couple examples if you guys like for
airborne effectiveness if you want to
take frontiers cry with precision hand
cannon bonus acres grip and lucky pants
you get your airborne effectiveness up
to 79.
with submission icarus grip stompies and
tempered metal
you've got
12th whale
so yeah stompies is gonna make building
into airborne effectiveness just
difficult and that may be one you might
have to try and find every other way to
make it effective or you've just got to
learn to aim better and that's one of
those things if they want to reward the
people who are good at aiming because
they said the randomness of the accuracy
cone is actually going to be less but
aim assist is also going to be less if
you're in the air
also like take sky burner's health and
oath and heat rises you're literally
capped at 100. so then you can use
another exotic you don't even need the
wings of sacred dawn at that point so if
you're just floating in the sky
peppering people with sky burner's oath
you're good to go you're like you're
staying on the ground now granted i
don't expect a whole lot of people to
start using sky burn yourself like it's
god mode
but it is going to be um
i don't know i don't i don't know sky
burner's oath hasn't traveled
[Music]
comes back i'll buy you an extra drink
at gcx that's that so nice you've got
your oh it's coming back already
even then you can stay up in the air
with whatever you want on the warlock
but you can be shocked because you're
static to a degree
hunters will never static with with
storm peas
yeah please uh if you plan on using this
exotic subscriber please uh please tag
me on twitter with the hashtag take the
oath
and
let me know how you're going to be
dominating with this things yeah that
will that will be the hashtag for this
episode tag or take the oath
if you're going to be dominating with
sky burner's oath in pvp and i want to
see clips you got to tag any of us and
that will be great shout out real quick
he's going to be so confused when he
sees me getting tagged for take the oath
did you start a cult what happened dude
what is going on in here sure did [ __ ]
you missed it yeah shout out real quick
to mri gamer just become a patreon
member because your master lost sector's
help vids are worth the dollar a month
alone hope anyone that how your vids
have helped consider us donate honestly
like yeah i appreciate the patreon i
actually saw the alert on my phone uh
but thank you very much for the 10 super
chat appreciate the support for
everything that we got going on here on
the channel so appreciate that mri gamer
thank you very much
uh but that is most of it for airborne
um but that is that's huge their
new stat on a weapon
uh stompy's getting a pretty good chunk
but it's the idea that if you are a
player who enjoys being very vertical
uh and honestly it's the people who have
verticality is that last piece of skill
for a lot of people a lot of people as
you said mondo they do run on that
horizontal plane they're not looking up
nearly as much so when you start to add
verticality to a playstyle it is that
that level of high skilled player that's
typically going to be vertical
and they want to
yeah it's like they want to still allow
that person to build into that way if
they want to
but on the other side it is going to be
something you have to lean into a little
bit more but also they said if you're
good at aiming you're still probably
going to get rewarded by it if you lean
into it so i'll be curious to see how
this plays out stompy's as travis said
it sounds like those are going to be
probably a bit reverted later on but now
they just they probably want to get data
about other exotics because that thing's
probably just like the big chunk of the
bar graph for too long they want to see
what else is out there which is probably
fine
uh playlist weapons
those are
pretty much just going to have it sounds
like playlist weapons now have a chance
to roll with extra traits
in the third and fourth column
and it increases with the number of rank
resets during that season so if you play
and live in the strike playlist you just
like i log on i have time to play
strikes well the more you spend time in
zavala's playlists
and you rank him up you're actually
going to have a chance to get some of
those weapons that are now going to have
two perks in those slots so if it's a
season
that has a really god-tier weapon in a
certain playlist you're gonna see people
playing it even more to have a chance
because a lot of those weapons have like
200 perks in each slot they're just
ridiculous to try and get a god roll for
it's not that many it's usually like 12
but it's still a lot for
statistical chances um they also said
they're going to
basically have a chance for
all playlist weapons from beyond late
and later will drop with the appropriate
origin trade as well so they're gonna
get a little update there
so basically if you love to live in a
playlist if you're one of the few people
who main gambit
you will probably be getting a little a
little more chances at a god roll out of
there there are a few of you
and whoever you are more power to you
um but if it strikes the crucible and
there's a good weapon that sees it and
you live in that playlist you're
probably going to
start to see some drops that get you a
lot closer to what you're going for
that's a random thing the stat display
not much is good nothing's going to
change for the weapon functionality
but they said all stat weapon bars are
going to go now from a range of 0 to 100
instead of some being limited in the
middle of the bar
so it's like the stat bars are going to
look different on weapons but now
everything is going to be universal
0-100 just random change
all right next big topic
one hit kills and special ammo before i
even get into this
for those of you for you two how much
are one-hit kills and annoyance do you
feel they're fair not fair where are you
guys at right now on
just one hit kill weapons between
snipers fusions
all of those ariana's vow or layman arc
and there's something they are going to
change like the ariana's val standing in
an empowering rift or layman arc doing
the same thing that they're actually
going to change and take away
so i mean that is
probably i would guess a good change for
most people because there shouldn't be
one tapping but on the other side mostly
just about special weapons getting one
taps in general where are you guys at
just on those do you like that they're
an option or do you feel they're too
frequent where are you guys at on those
i'll let uh monday go first
thank you
no
uh i thought i
i think in the game
i think one hit kills any weapon that
can one hit kill should require a build
or a skill to go into that
but i i
i don't think and now when i say that i
don't think just putting down
an emperor in breath and hitting someone
with a ball should constitute or should
be able to one hit kill because that's
is cheap
i think a sniper with a headshot no
bodies headshot should should one hit
kill
i think
i think the sharper one
i think the chaperone once you proc
roadborn
should then have that capability but i'm
unsure how much damage or how much
distance you should be with one shot
with i certainly don't want to be one
shot by someone using the chaperone
while they're looking at another tv you
know as the chaperone almost kills by
itself so i think
i think one shot one shot killed weapons
as long as you know
as long as when you get killed by that
weapon you can accept
that that was a good shot or that was a
play instead of being like man that is
that's so cheap so with some of the
changes i'm making i'm okay with it but
i'm okay with
with one hit kills as long as
that there needs to be some time
investment or just a natural skill with
that weapon to be able to do it i just
think they should be few and far between
because high-skilled weapons that can do
that shouldn't be able to be used by
by everybody
and and and as i say it should take a
lot of skill to do that makes it makes
the matches just a little bit fairer i
think
yeah what about you travis just in
general i know chaperones one of your
babies but i mean snipers shotguns
fusions just all of that middle tier in
general
yeah i mean i think there are some
things that should one hit right
uh tomato's point headshot on sniper
should get one one hit i think fusion
rifles should one hit at certain
distances if you hit all of your the
parts of your blast yeah just because
those require a
a a charge time yep um i think shotguns
should one hit uh hit kill if you're
like right up close you center mass you
know getting them off of the pellets
giving them a hug with the shotgun
sliding into them and just blasting them
right in the in their chest that's just
useless do you think it does too much
range
chaperone yeah oh yeah for sure it does
i mean i i think i think there should be
precision if you're using if you're
doing a pellet
uh shotgun basically you're putting all
of your dps into one precision point and
i think that that should be able to hit
because it's it's hard to hit those but
i have
i have problems with the way chaperone
uh aim assists and the way that uh
someone's told and get a crap
yeah it's it's it's cheesy it's cheesy
it's it's ranges too far you know it it
has problems uh 100 percent agree that
it should be with one apple
it should be one hit i mean it should
for for anything that's precision like
that i think it should but i don't think
bo should be able to hit you like that's
crazy that you can even build into that
i think they should prevent that from
happening i don't think yotan should
want to
hit kill that's
crazy to me yeah but on the other side
like dodging yo if i actually know
somebody's playing yodan and i get hit
by it and then i start knowing it's
coming it's not the hardest thing in the
world to dodge either i've been hit by a
plenty but i also know it's like if i'm
smart about it i can move
aside like what are they done with with
the autumn sorry a silent thing they've
done with your turn is if you've got
your resilience above 80 it can't eat it
can't one-hit kill you
it's good to know i i don't think i have
my resilience i'm an intellect
oh well yeah you'll eventually die
if you move when you get hit your thing
if it hits you you move straight away
my problem with yotan is that it's a
fusion rifle that you can shoot from
really far away and it just allows you
to spam it and if you can get one hit
kill with something that easily it's
like
you'll get killed when you're not
like skilllessly peek around a corner
and shoot at a dude who's not looking at
him and then the guy just gets burnt
right away yeah dudes probably got
stompies on as well no i'm joking yeah
yeah exactly he's like shooting at you
from the sky so it should uh it should
definitely burn you down and they should
be able to like finish you off super
easily with a primary but the fact that
it just instantly kills you from across
the map is like so annoying it's just so
cheesy so i think there's some things
they can do to reign it in on the other
hand i think that there's things that
it's ridiculous that they don't want hit
kill you like i still think grenades
that stick onto you should kill you they
should just redo they should reduce the
the homing and the the uh
yeah like if you got a station
you have to you have no aim assist but
if you stick it on them they're dead no
questions the more skill it takes to use
the more damage it should do i'm pretty
sure they actually said that yeah
exactly
my problem with the way that they've
done grenades is they basically went the
other way they were like let's make them
do as little damage as possible but
they'll be super easy to land and i just
feel like that doesn't feel super good
i don't know if we've ever talked about
grenades that much be i miss being able
to stick people yeah it was way too easy
in d1 because it was like let me hook
this thing around the corner and stick
it on your shoulder and kill you but
again if you do get that lob or you're
running at him you chunk it and you get
that stick and it's on their chest like
if this explodes on my shoulder blade i
should die because it's on me for sure
yeah i i think it's ridiculous why would
you throw a grenade why would you build
into a cool down for a grenade if it
just does chip damage that you could
accomplish with like shooting them with
the pulse rifle you know i mean it just
doesn't make any sense from like a game
design perspective and i kind of feel
similarly about special melees like
anything where you have a cool down
there should be more skill involved
obviously but there should be some way
to like get kills with those i i feel so
yeah um i don't know i feel like they've
got some tuning to do when it comes with
some of the public melees one that
killed i mean like a throwing knife will
do it and like
you should do it then
but i mean there's not many that
i don't
know i was like it feels like sometimes
that won't kill you and there's no i
don't think that i i think after they
did the titan shoulder rams i don't
think you think those even won't yeah
outside of
greaves that's about it yeah
yeah um so yeah they did the change to
empowering rift high energy fire inertia
override
down from 20 to 15 percent basically
they took up the ability away for those
one-hit cheap kills to go away which is
good
but they also went to special ammo
they've been trying to figure this out
for a very long long time to figure out
what is a good amount of special ammo
trying to lean more into primary ammo
gun fights and they straight up
lowered scavenger what it was doing
before they still feel like that's not
enough so now they have straight up
disabled ammo scavenger and pvp
altogether no matter how much ammo a
player was carrying on death if you pick
up a special brick you can only get one
ammo for a shotgun or sniper i'm
guessing fusion's the same way or one
kills worth of ammo for a weapon that
requires more than one shot like foe
runner 4runner tracer rifles
so basically you're going to get one
kills worth of ammo if you pick up a
special brick
scavenger does now nothing in pvp in
season 17.
uh they retuned several special weapon
archetypes and exotic weapons which are
below
with the general goal of reducing the
effectiveness and uptime of special
weapons
they want those one-hit kills to be less
frequent like those moments if you do
get a pick it should mean a lot with
like say a sniper rifle but on the other
side if you start
roaming a 6v6 and you're just like
snipes or shotguns and you're sitting on
like 20 20 ammo for your shotgun you
just shot cha cha cha everywhere they
don't want that to happen so that seems
to be what they're going for they want
to get the primary ammo back as much as
they can into the gameplay do you guys
think disabling scavenger is too far or
do you feel like this is a fair decision
too much or too little
this is the one area where i felt like i
was reading the
the twab and felt like ugh
are we really going back here
you know you know how many times they've
tried this i feel like i've read this
exact wob over and over again
every single time they go hey we want to
make you know special ammo less
prominent we want to make it so you only
get one brick we want to make it so blah
blah and then eventu inevitably they
implement it and then it makes crucible
super boring because everybody's just
using canned cannons and pulse rifles
and all the stuff that they use
uh
to you know to just make the
make yourself
get a few maybe one or two kills before
you die and then get your special ammo
back yeah and uh i just i feel like that
we've we've retreaded this so many times
and they keep flip-flopping on it so i i
mean i don't necessarily have a problem
with their strategy of like okay well
you shouldn't just be able to spam
special ammo because then nobody uses
primary i get that that's a problem it
just feels like they have they still
have not come up with a good solution
for this and and they've i've seen this
exact two note
like at least two times before in
destiny's history where they're like
yeah we're gonna reduce
ammo economy for a special you're only
gonna be able to pick up one brick per
kill and every time i just roll my eyes
and i'm just like dude
you tried this already like come up with
a different solution for this problem so
i don't know i i have a feeling that
this is gonna get reversed yet again
because players always complain about
not being able to use their special
weapons and how gameplay gets boring
when you're just shooting primaries at
each other which is something that i
kind of agree with and so i i just i i
don't see this
panning out because i've seen them fail
at it at least two other times
so
i don't know i i this is the one part of
the swabber is just like really again
we're back here we're having this
conversation again
mondo what about you
i don't know if you're as much of a pvp
guy or not but do you feel like this is
oh i'm i'm i'm incredible at least three
hours every day i wondered where you
spent for 7 500 hours so that's 7 500
hours
uh how do you know that
i didn't even know how many hours i had
wasted on destiny.com and i looked up
live and i'm guessing the guy who has 7
500 hours probably you
yeah that would be correct
[Laughter]
i don't know i kind of agree with travis
i've seen this before i've seen the
reducing the special animal economy and
then you're going to crucible maybe the
next week after it's been patched and
some guys just been running around for
eight minutes with a shotgun and hasn't
equipped a primary so i don't know where
they go with this but
every time i read this i just
i don't know it's a feeling more than i
thought that they're still trying to go
back to the double primary heavy thing
because the chris maybe because the
crucible maps that are in destiny even
the ones they brought forward
really don't seem that they seem like
they'd be made with a different matter
in mind and it's like rather than fix
the maps
i i don't know it just always feels to
me as if
the special ammo thing
you couldn't go back to d1 whether it
was special ammo box i i don't know what
they do about this you know i don't know
if this is the right thing i don't know
if
you know this is going to be a bad thing
i really don't have a lot of investment
in this so i'm not like
i'm kind of like oh that's
that's another thing that was special
yeah we'll see how this one pans out for
sure exactly yeah i mean
i wonder why they're just on that bit
that that they've put that then they've
spoke a ton about snipers
if they're reducing the special animal
why are they worried about snipers now
i don't know
well they do address the fact that that
the special animal changes aren't really
going to affect snipers anyway so yeah
because snipers can't collect the ammo
from the people that killed this time
because yeah they gave snipers a little
bit more snappiness we'll get to in the
archetypes so they were a little easier
to use but as you typically don't pick
up your ammo from across the map you're
usually not going to get a lot more
shots about that yeah it's kind of those
things like you want
it's nice to have the flexibility of a
special weapon because
it gives you
a different feel of play style yeah it
gives you a different feel of hold on i
have to get in this gun fight every so
often is nice to like be you know turn
around that corner see your radar and
know that your shotgun is going to kill
or if you're on contingency and you're
looking way down a lane and you do get a
pick or if you actually do manage to get
that charge up it feels good it is to a
point and i think this is what they're
as both of you guys have said
when they're trying to balance the idea
of
the person who's already got tier
matchmaking is a bit of a mess we know
right now anyway but if that person is
that very high skill level now is just
like circling the map constantly
refilling their
special weapon with more than they feel
is viable
as opposed to kill for ammo it's kill
get two or three ammo kill get two or
three ammo and now they've got like six
shots just to pump down a lane with a
sniper rifle and probably get one if
they're good enough they're really
trying to reel in how often that is i'm
with you guys though i don't want to go
all the way back to that double
primaries because it does feel nice to
have those moments they're just trying
to figure out the balance of how often
those moments happen i think 100 percent
so
yeah it's like i feel like this might
have trails in mind though
i mean maybe a little they already did
trials to where if you get revived your
special's gone which is yeah so that's
already kind of been a piece of a thing
in there like if you get revived you're
on primary anyway unless you just get
lucky to find some in that round yeah
that was also
won't really matter because usually
those matches are pretty quickly and
either the special ammo is spent and
everybody's just kind of shooting
primaries and using abilities or
it's not spent yet and it's about to and
that's how you get your kills so it's
already kind of not dominant in trials i
don't think there's a way around that
just because you're dying and restarting
the round so many times
we do have some interesting graphs when
you get to archetypes though because
these special weapons in particular
shotguns and fusions are responsible for
more one-hit kills than they'd like in
pvp literally what they say
shotguns by far though
it's like 55 of them
and it's been consistent
almost
how far do you go back i mean this is
data for
basically january through now so i mean
three months before witch queen after
which queen there was a little blip of
glaives when everybody had to do their
bounties and then that went away glaives
are basically
minimally there grenade launchers have
their little piece linear fusions have a
smaller piece snipers have you know
about 18
fusion rifles have about 18 shotguns
have the rest it is just a massive
massive chunk so
special weapons they say all special
weapons that have had their in-air
accuracy significantly reduced so again
they're leaning into that if you want it
you got to build into it
special weapons have slightly larger
airborne accuracy penalty than primary
weapons special weapons have smaller
airborne aim assist cone
penalty to other weapons around fifty
percent at a zero stat and this penalty
converter can be reduced but not
entirely removed by investing in
airborne if you try and use a special
weapon while airborne it is just going
to be very difficult
uh but for sniper rifles as we just said
they reduce the steady the stow ready
and aim down sightsees by 10 so all
snipers are gonna feel snappier and
that's mostly because they felt like
snapshot had to be mandatory to be
useful so all of them are going to be a
little better snapshot's going to feel
about the same so if you do have a
sniper that doesn't have snapshot it
might feel a little better if you have
good perks on it so don't just get rid
of it if you see one without snapshot
might be feel a little bit little bit
better coming up soon
and now we get to the shotgun details
first slug and pellet shotguns are still
overwhelmingly popular in pvp
so they've reduced the damage fall off
start and end by one meter so the damage
fall off on both ends has been brought
back a meter
and they reduce the aim assisted
magnetism fall off start and end by two
meters
so
shorter distances for shotgun kills once
again
and also the aim assist probably more
for slugs coming back as well so it's
going to reduce the one-hit kill
distance of most shotguns by around they
say about a half a meter somewhere in
the realm of probably about a meter
depending on if it's slug or shotguns
think you guys are going to feel it that
much or you think you're just going to
have to give them a little bit more of a
hug
i probably
already get closer than i need to with
my shotguns just out of like paranoia so
yeah um yeah i don't particularly mind
this change it does feel cheesy and not
good to get killed by a shotgun at far
distance especially when
uh you know fusion rifle users are
supposed to be rewarded for having to
charge up their weapons to get kills at
that same distance and so
this is something that another problem
that they struggled with i feel like
forever and and they're never getting
like the
shotgun distance kill
raiding right and sometimes they
overdo
how far you can get a kill of fusions
but
they still need to figure it out like
there has to be kind of a a nice path
where shotguns have a sweet spot for
getting kills and fusions have a sweet
spot and then everything else far
distance has a sweet spot so
the fact that
shotguns are so dominant i think might
have more to do with the game getting
faster over the years
being faster and things being quicker
and when that happens and it's easier to
get close to somebody why wouldn't you
use a shotgun so i think that um that
that has more to do with it than
anything mechanically about the shotguns
and they they can't make shotguns like
swords basically where you have to be
like within melee range to to actually
get a kill so
um you know i i don't know what the what
the right answer is here but i i do
think that it is probably time for
shotguns to get tuned down in terms of
the distance which they could get a
one-hit kill so especially slug throwers
like i get it takes skill but it's uh
it's it's a little insane that you can
get popped from so far away with the
i mean that's why i've been using it for
so long yeah i used it even before it
was the meta i've been using chaperone
for a long time just because i like the
feel of it and
uh yeah so
mondo
yeah yeah i i changed from
from sniper to shotgun because i found
it
kinda more
it was just getting too difficult to
challenge because i think travis made a
brilliant point there that shotguns are
being told dominant because
movement and abilities being able to
close that
up a lot faster than you could ever do
before so as someone who
enjoyed sniping and reasonable sniper i
felt like i couldn't compete because a
shotgun i could just close that distance
i fee so
hey if you can't beat them i joined them
you know and started using that shot
so i love the snipe but just yeah it's
the same here yeah that mobility is a
big one that's true
abilities as well being you know
it started with uh
the warlock being able to dash and stuff
and
you know
but i i i think i think they do need a
tune but only just if i'm being honest
the main point for me would be just to
kind of
put a wooden spoon in the sandbox just
mix things up a little bit and you know
let's get some let's get some different
weapons out there
yeah
yeah i mean you guys pretty much covered
it i mean just bring them in a little
tighter the mobility already allows them
to as you said close the gap really fast
icarus dash you know titans moving
around the ability that you can see like
the high skilled people just like book
it down a lane you're going damn
no wonder they do that all the time so
it's like yeah the high skilled people
you're gonna have to get a little bit
closer but it's not much but you're
gonna have to make the shots count if
you're a good shotgunner this isn't
gonna affect you too much probably not
you're just going to have to like you
know probably get a little bit of the
muscle memory of how big is that
guardian so i know i'm in the right
range
yeah personally if you're using
especially if you're using felt winter
still which a lot of people are for some
reason yeah why
[Laughter]
it's a crutch man
uh fusion rifle usage is trending pretty
high in particular in trials
um probably on account of observer
selling a couple god rolls here and
there and amongst other things
bringing wit and with bringing shotguns
down a little bit seems like it would
make him too good of an option they also
feel like changes they don't want to see
20-plus meter fusion rifle one-hit kills
so most of this looks like it's gonna
bring fusion rifles back basically a
couple of meters two to like one to two
meters on most of this stuff
recoil scaler a little bit but the
damage fall off distance
is going to be
a little bit more uh or a little bit
less reduced damage fall off near
distance is going to be a little bit
less so it's just they're going to be
effective a little closer so when people
you know
damage testing people like fallout and
stuff they'll be like yeah i think i can
get one like 21 meters it might be like
19 meters now it's still if you plan it
right you should be able to out hit a
shotgun
but it's definitely one of those where
you're not going to be able to get quite
as far
they had their air until broke fusions
for a while then main ingredient did it
and then now they're trying to reel them
back and as you said travis they're
trying to find trying to basically find
their sweet spots it is hilarious to
look at this graph though
because you can see main ingredient had
a big bubble for a while because it was
sold by zur noel composure had a pretty
good while there because of decent chunk
for a while because it was the pursuit
weapon a lot of people had it then you
can literally see which queen launched
likely suspect kind of got a big big
bubble and then snoring got a decent
bubble main ingredient was sold by zur
the that piece of the graph got
absolutely massive for about a weekend
came back down a little bit to where it
was still a massive chunk though and you
can see which ones are the popular ones
right now between deliverance likely
suspect main ingredients nori is
actually pretty popular right now and
you can see some other ones like zealous
award or like why am i even here so it
is funny to see
you can literally pinpoint where zur
sells certain weapons or if it's a
trials weekend and stuff it's very
obvious
and it like so it is just funny to
actually see the data i like these
graphs though because it is interesting
to see i wish i could see it a little
bit longer i get that it wouldn't be
very visible but it is interesting to
see this type of stuff i actually would
like to see it more often like every so
often to kind of get a quarterly update
when they do a sandbox be like hey where
are some of these special weapons at or
where are some of the primaries i'd be
curious what the primaries look like
because i know hand cannons have got to
be pretty damn high up there there's no
way zero usage
lies lice
uh also with fusion rifles they did say
they rebuilt him in season 15 but they
wanted to get them a little farther
apart
so now the hip the high impacts they
wanted to bring the charge time down
just a little bit so instead of uh
basically a thousand charge time it's
going to be 960 and they increase the
damage per burst by
uh precisions which are going to be like
your main ingredient they uh increased
unmodified charge time from 740 to 780.
rapid fires which is going to be like
your timelines vertex that's going to be
from fort oh sorry not rapid fires rapid
fire is like uh null composure for
example is going to go from 460 to 500
and they decrease the damage per burst
by 20
and then so you're gonna have to hit
more of your perks your bolts there
and then the adaptives are kind of where
they are at 660 with 270.
so precisions have an intrinsic piece to
them that's why they're a little slower
charge time
at 280 total damage adaptives are 270 at
660. they're just trying to give the
fusion rifles a little bit more um
basically distinction between each of
the types
does this sound like anything that's
going to change what you guys are using
anything good or bad here for you guys
i do
yeah
it's never going to be as bad as when
aaron tail was around that's true
that was mapping people way way too far
away
do you feel like it wasn't really a
fusion rifle it outplayed the range that
a fusion rifle should be efficient for
so
are affected from
main ingredients of gopro
you know and it's it's okay it's strong
but it's a gobble
expect it to do do what it says on the
tin but these changes are all pretty
cool yeah
yeah i don't have a problem with these
either i've i've seen fusion rifle have
increased usage and crucible lately and
i've also used it a little bit not as
not as much but
um
yeah i don't think any of these are
really big game changers this is sort of
just like housekeeping in my my opinion
like yeah
fusion rifles are in a pretty good spot
there's a few of them that are maybe too
good but you got to respect the people
that grinded for those
roles that can really like compete with
a shotgun or stuff sometimes i get
surprised it must be really difficult to
go and buy it from tsar
because you know that meaning yeah yeah
the main ingredient is what honestly
changed all of this is there having so
much about just practice two or three
fusion rifles if sir hadn't sold two or
three
you would not see this kind of usage
because most people
have not been lucky enough to get that
god roll
so it is interesting that zur selling
one thing in people and there's enough
people in the world that are like hey go
buy this fusion rifle people start
trying it getting a feel for it i
honestly like the fact that it brought
fusion rifles
usage up as some way to combat
shotguns and i'm just like hey i will
happily fusion rifle a shotgun user if
he's running at me and i can voop him
right before he gets to me i'm good with
it so but it's just it's just a spike
isn't it it's just beautiful trying out
it's like it's it's not like the usage
the usage is
a consistent block where it's lasting
for
months you know we've seen that yeah
it's like you can look back because they
go back to january and i think both
fusion rifles that zero sold has been
from january onward and you can see some
little blips where it looks like it's
been sold and been a little bigger
shotguns still have dominated and
drastically dominated i think it's
honestly just because if i turn around
the corner
and you know know that somebody's close
i can get that one hit kill infusion
rifles takes a little more play takes
managing your corners and things under
understanding your radar a little bit
more so it's still never going to be as
easy to use as a shotgun but now people
have ones that are going to be more
effective if they actually start playing
with them before one that was actually
just sold by zur
uh trace rifles which most people don't
use that often uh they increase trace
rifle damage against non-red bar
combatants by 20
and ammo pick up her special brick from
18 to 30.
you can melt a red bar with a trace
rifle that's not too bad but i feel like
if you do fight an orange or bar or a
boss you're just like
shooting it for a very long time and not
doing very much so trace rifles are
going to be getting a little bit of buff
in pve because they said besides
divinity trace rifles don't get much and
the fact that we now have legendary
trace rifles will get to exotics that
actually seem to get buffed as well
primary weapons they say autos and
pulses feel like they can't quite
compete at range so auto rifles got a
tiny buff of like three quarters of a
meter pulse rifles are bumped out by
about a meter meter and a half nothing
too major
zoom on smgs
all of the people that were talking
about the multi muk that's like a sniper
that thing's being brought down from 17
to 15. second highest zoom is going to
be 14. shire's wrath it is a trials
weapon so they do say those are always
going to be a little bit stronger they
increase the damage fall off from
submachine guns also by a meter and a
half a lot of the zoom on the other smgs
got brought up a bit a little bit so
they kind of squish the range uh that
zoom's gonna affect smgs and also
brought some of the outliers down quite
a bit
um and then we get to heavies this is
exciting machine guns aren't what they
want them to be in pvp and i feel like
we do i feel like this is one of those
times travis where you're like i feel
like i've read this before
this is what it was for rockets before
because rockets what did they get a 30
damage buff and everybody's like where's
the rocket buff where's the rocket buff
two years later thirty percent and what
we were like hey we could take like ten
ten no do it all in that chunk so now
machine guns increase damage by forty
percent against pve enemies twenty
percent versus bosses and then xenophage
and now the grand overture new one they
get the 40 buff against enemies except
the bonus versus bosses they do not get
i mean 40 you're almost talking to i say
it's almost 50 and i know that's like a
stupid statement but you're literally
almost giving something a 50 buff
that tells you how bad it was for a
while and we've been at they've been
feeling not great so now you've got
things like corrective measure and
thunderlord these machine guns that are
now potentially going to be putting in
some work do you guys think you actually
might pull them back out of your vault
i'll let you go with that travis i've
actually got a really good answer here
oh well then let me go first with my
shitty answer
exactly no i'm joking
yeah i think so uh i i've always liked
uh machine guns it's just that they've
never been the meta and i like having
plentiful ammo i like the way that they
feel the way that they sound and i think
in pve especially um you know the
problem is that
you can just blow through a lot of your
ammo just like trying to kill a couple
majors and then you end up just kind of
going all right well now i've got to
spend 45 minutes reloading the weapon so
i don't know what the point of that was
yeah so yeah i think uh 40 is probably
overkill i'm sure that they'll have to
lower that especially with the changes
they made to xeno which we'll get to
later but uh uh i think uh
this is
good i would like to see uh
machine guns make a return to the meta
but we'll see we'll see what happens but
yeah probably um
probably over over pumping up would be
my guess
i
i literally i must have i must have had
some sort of epiphany
because the last master i'd done i ran a
machine gun
as my heavy slot couldn't believe how
good it was and i realized you actually
mentioned the machine gun
because it was the one from vogue
absolutely tore through champions all i
had to do was break the shield over i
always run a weakening grenade so i put
the grenade on and that was that they
weren't getting a chance they just
disappeared
when i seen they were going to buff that
by 40 percent now corrective measure has
quite a large ammo capacity i think it's
like 269 or something but because of
slower fire rate
you're not really gonna burst through
all your ammo really quickly
i i never had a problem with ammo and
when i seen that forty percent
my first thing i thought of was
we're going right back to thunderlord oh
yeah
even though we're not doing it against
bosses but i remember and it was insane
a inverted spire
i equipped it
and i ran the whole strike
never took it off that's a nightfall
never used anything but thunderlord
let's drop an ammo left right and center
and then melted the boss with it
never had to use another weapon used
that for the whole strike
and i was thinking of myself as much as
as we well i think we all know machine
guns are kind of been gathering
but not because they've been bad it's
because other things like linear fusion
rifles with particle deconstruction and
then you had grenade launchers with
breaching clear other things to took the
limelight
machine guns did get a buff a while ago
right 20 percent or something i honestly
can't remember complimentary
one yeah
uh so i had them in my head when when i
seen that i'm definitely going to use
them see what they're like and it was
literally only yesterday i was like i
was going to do that machine gun thing
and this was before the twap came up
yeah and then when i seen that i always
like to do it
yeah
i'm definitely going to be using machine
guns but i i agree
that's going to get brought down
that is going to get because pve enemies
20 against bosses champions aren't
considered bosses nope
they are immediately a major category
yeah
so
yeah that'll be interesting
i mean i haven't been feeling like i've
been able to use xenophage got nerfed
and didn't feel good which they did
change by the way we'll get to that
later for exotics uh avalanche
commemoration even the new one now that
you can get stats for all one for all i
know the stasis one's like a i feel like
it's a 900 rpm and those aren't really
my favorite
but if you can get that one for all and
a machine gun to proc which hitting
three enemies with a machine gun you
already got a lot of bullets anyway if
you can get that to proc and then you
have like stats for all one for all like
i've got on one of those
40 plus 35 to everything
or 20 you know 55 to a boss that's like
70 damage if you can get that to proc
next season yeah there's gonna be some
fun with machine guns but yeah
thunderlord with its lightning bringing
down
i think they'll be i think people will
be doing damage tests with like
xenophage grand overture which also get
a bit of a tweak and then stuff like
corrective measure you've got
avalanche commemoration games is
bringing the
arabic catalyst for oh
and that thing's got a shield at least
that thing's not crazy to hear in pvp
anymore man when that thing was like you
could hear people spit it up i was like
oh god somebody's walking around with an
impossible shield i'm glad that got
nerfed run
run
so yeah i haven't gotten to use machine
guns in a while so i'm just happy to see
them come back because we've been asking
it's felt like they've needed it and we
were right when they go this big we knew
they needed it probably as you guys say
that will be brought down a little bit
rocket launchers are getting a bit more
of a distinction precision frame which
is going to be like your polymedia with
intrinsic tracking uh it's going to get
a minus 10 percent damage to both impact
and detonation high impact are staying
about the same they have the biggest
blast radius adaptive and aggressive
rocket launchers picture your hot heads
um that's just one i know because i
looked up but any adaptive or aggressive
is getting 10 bonus damage so if you
take the precision which is going to be
your intrinsic tracking
like your hockeys versus an adaptive
that's a 20 difference in rocket
launcher damage if you're doing any of
the rocket launcher
dps strats you might theoretically need
to look at which one you're using 20
could make a big difference so
that was one i saw that was pretty big
exotics
i'm gonna try and go through a couple of
the highlights here some of the big ones
fighting lion
um blast radius increased by a little
bit damage up by five percent apparently
they just wanted a little bit back
better eyes of tomorrow since you did
finally get it damaged versus bosses and
champions is 30 percent more apparently
they're trending at one time
with uh in real life titan yeah yeah
leviathan's recorded that video i was
shooting it for the first time yeah i
think i do remember that one
leviathan's breath they are trying to
make this happen i feel like fetching
mean girls he's trying to make it yeah
it's like they're trying to make it
happen i don't know if it's ever gonna
pay off because like it's so slow they
said the archer's tempo is instead of
gonna be like three quarters speed
reduction for arch tempo it's now almost
gonna be 50 reduction they said they
also added a small delay before the
detonation on champions so you would
literally like stun and then get your
damage
they basically describe it as an
increase in damage across the board of
about 50 percent
overall damage versus champions is
roughly doubled
and even more compared to shooting an
unstunned unstoppable champion
i still don't know if i'm ever gonna
make this my unstoppable weapon because
if you never need big dps it just
doesn't feel like it's there
but maybe i don't know i still feel like
the idea of a slow drawing giant bow to
do dps it better hit like a mack truck
or it just doesn't seem like enough do
you think this is enough mondo
what
you're not gonna take any reactivity
okay no
but if you add that 50
plus on that
with a 25
void burn
because acute gives you 25 yeah i think
you're in the right nightfall and and
the fact that
unknown to a lot of people this actually
does a lot of damage to champions
already yeah
so
yeah i'm trying to make a good case for
it uh
and i'm feeling miserably i i don't know
if the only way i would equip this is to
finally dispel the triple ball nightfall
that i keep getting asked to do oh
avoiding like the plague
but uh
yeah it might it might get it a little
button but more use but
still no just have to wait and see we're
just up to wins yeah it's just one of
those that it's it's cool in concept but
i never feel like it was worth the time
the limited ammo
just have to see huckleberry got its
zoom
increased so it should get a little
better range usage xenophage as we said
they're basically reverting when they
made it harder hitting and slower it did
not feel good so they're basically
reverting most of that back and
yeah i know i i was like oh this feels
good all this sucks like it was weird
how that little change which i didn't
expect i wasn't
i really did not like how it felt so
it's going back to 120 uh they reduced
the damage per pullet to basically match
what it used to be but it is getting the
40 damage buff just not bosses so it's
gonna be back to how it was which i'm
good with so
i'm happy with that
lame arc is too oppressive when combined
with external damage buffs we already
know that one so you're not going to be
able to do the one tap but they reduce
the poison tick damage versus players
only by 25
change the poison damage from burn to
poison
uh they said that's largely housekeeping
i wonder if that's one of those like
back-end things for like that future
subclass they're trying to build maybe
you know it is it has to be right that
feels like one of those things like they
re-label it you know yeah this is
totally not a thing please don't pay
attention to this thing that could be a
thing uh but they increase the poison
tick damage by 50 versus combatants
which
i'll take if you are gonna go and use
that tick damage i will take a bonus
there
so i'm good with that make laminar more
powerful in pve yep
i'm good i'm pretty sure it's really
powerful in pve
well it's about to be a little bit more
fun so find a void burn and
only shell
lawrence driver uh they said could be
difficult to fight against in pvp so
they reduce the body shot damage by 20
body damage reverts to old behavior when
the weapons damage is in its bonus mode
precision damage and any mode is
unchanged basically they were saying
you could get very high body shot damage
and almost have a really easy follow-up
they wanted to get rid of that change
seems reasonable sky burner's oath one
of the biggest changes that i think it
got
so they increased yeah
let's see those on twitter
if you guys tag travis like get me give
me a bonus tag in there i want to see
you guys do that but i need clips you
can't just like tweet an empty tag i
want to see clips
i want to see you taking that oath
skyberger's oath got increased ads
projectile speed to hit scan which i
guess it wasn't before both ads and
hipfire are now 150 rpm head fire
projectors no longer projectiles no
longer track
but it arcs kind of like a grenade
launcher but has larger ads or has
larger detonation size hip fire
detonation also applies burn to targets
uh and the bonus range from the
masterwork has been rolled into the base
stats so it's just got more range in
general and the masterwork now grants
reload speed and it has the highest
airborne effectiveness so you really are
meant to be a floating ac 130 which is
trying to live up to its name at this
point it seems
you guys actually going to pull this
thing out of the vault and go try and we
need cog to do it because he's going to
be the warlock floaty guy up there with
the solar burn and just hanging out so
warlocks if you see any ac 130s coming
through pvp just you know getting
covered that's all i got to say
i'm going to take the oath absolutely
last
reduce mouse and keyboard recoil penalty
penalty from 33 to 22
i really hope i don't see more on pc
please i don't need to see last word
more
i'm not saying i see it that often but i
don't want to see it any more than i
already do
you will i'm probably true the one that
hurts me i'm sure there's a case for it
but this one hurts me arbalist had its
damage reduced versus champions by 25
percent still getting hit your boss is
still gonna hit you thanks
thank you
man i enjoy that weapon
it's like
it's a crutch it is i'm not gonna argue
because it breaks all shields it's a
barrier weapon and it hit pretty hard it
is only against
champions so it's like you can still do
some good damage against like elites and
stuff with it so it is just champions
why you should be pro arbolous getting
nerfed
because
arbalest right now the only reason it's
popular is because it gets around bad
pve mechanics that bungie refuses to fix
well that's the reason i like it yeah
exactly that's the reason you like it so
without it without it in the sandbox it
will force bungie to address the real
issue which is that champions are not
good
they're broken half of the champions
don't even work right and without really
without arvolus there to save you from
how bad that is bungie is now going to
have to fix champions and so i say good
riddance get our bliss out there
reveal the ugly
wart the
the the the pustule that's that's on uh
destiny's pve sandbox that is
i just think i just think like this is
going to bring the uh the problem to
daylight it's like going to show that
like they need to fix the champions
issue um and so yeah i'm not a fan of
like workarounds that basically you have
to have this in your loadout if you want
to
uh be able to do an activity that has
champion that's champion heavy uh
because this is the one weapon that goes
around the mechanics just fix the
mechanic it's bad and so i i saw this
and i was like oh yeah that's going to
piss a lot of people off but also it's
overpowered it it gets around an issue
that bungie bradley needs to fix so fix
your champions what's what i say
yeah like
iraq said it it's like it's wishful
thinking again like anything related to
champions and shields like it feels so
intrinsic to the game i don't expect to
change that for a very long time if ever
but if this is even a tiny bit of a
catalyst to help with that cool
but yeah i'm like overloads
overloads are bought to be probably the
most annoying right now because we got a
new expansion
and you have to use auto rifles and smgs
against these most annoying enemies so
no it's like i get yeah i get it's a
crutch totally do but as you said when
you're dealing with multiple shield
types and then you got multiple
champions and your loadout can be like
two things it is very frustrating so i
hope at some point they listen to some
of the feedback enough of the videos
enough of the tweets the champions
reworked changed i actually had scaro9
and i just did a discord call offline
that i recorded i did that last night
with him and we talked about hard mode
vowel which we actually haven't talked
about yet which we gotta talk about
before we go
and or master val and then also
champions and some other things we
talked about
and
they brought up something
i saw something on twitter scourge of
the past
had the berserker guys
those were kind of like a type of
champion and unfortunately champions
have just been
i don't want to call a developer lazy
because again i know their priorities
and stuff but it's just like we made the
champions and we just never did anything
with them
and
the fact that it's been the same
barriers overloads and unstoppables
outside of now we have a score and
unstoppable but there hasn't been a
whole lot of
change variation update anything to the
champions in so long if they are going
to keep them in the game
a rework an update of changing how they
work new champions not just the same
damn three items like if one way or the
other get rid of them or
like do a full rework one way the other
anyway
that one i'm probably going to post up
saturdays if you want to see the chat
between scaro and i was actually just a
ton of fun last 20 minutes we fell off
the rails but either way check that one
out
graviton lance this one actually sounds
fun so the catalyst changed from hidden
hand which i don't even remember what
that did
it's going to get vorpal
and turnabout so graviton lance already
has a pulse rifle that causes cosmology
then it's going to have vorpal which is
going to do 20 because it is a primary
against
bosses and champions
uh exotics do 50 more against red bar
enemies because they got that buff to be
better and then turn about if you break
a void shield now you're gonna get an
overshield
so i don't at some point graviton lance
finally might get to see uh see its day
it does seem like it could have some
potential wasn't it wasn't it like
everybody's favorite gun for a while in
destiny 2. i feel like at the start of
destiny 2 it was fun and then it just
like has been
crying in that corner for like three
years
day it was like the pvp meta for a
really long time so it's just weird to
see it coming back because they went out
of their way to kill that weapon yep
slowly bringing it back grand overture
they said they reduced the time between
the burst of missile mode you can either
hold it down for all 20 or you can tap
for five round bursts on the missiles uh
coldheart they said most linear fusion
rifles now
don't have enough to set them apart as
we're getting regular legendary fusion
rifles so cold heart
the sustained damage is going to give
you ionic traces
which is going to help you with ability
energy which is interesting also the
grace time before the damage ramp goes
away goes from .113 seconds which is
kind of like a blink of an eye
uh to one second so you get a lot more
time to get back on target in case you
do get flinched or something prometheus
lends in the same way sustained damage
applies on more useful burned targets
wave splitter is basically getting
normalized and then if you pick up an
orb of power you're getting 10 seconds
of maximum power up to 20 seconds if you
get those orbs of power
osteostriga apparently the projectiles
were rotated by 90 degrees i will never
understand how that was a thing so sure
and this came out of the gun on the
wrong end yeah it was like came out
so yeah for whatever reason that's
getting fixed
uh i didn't even notice that no he's
like got a ton and i never noticed it
nope lord of wolves has its damage fall
off starting and reduced by about 25 so
lord of wolves is getting brought back
as well
any exotics in there that you guys see
that you want to shout out before we get
to perks and stuff
no
no i i would like to just address the
champion thing
go for it
yeah
which really covers all bliss i agree
that
i as i'm sure
everybody does the champions are
a waste of time at this point especially
when mods don't stop them and
but uh
i'm not really sure what they could do
to change champions now
because they've messed about with that
model so many times
the nightfall model
right
you know we had normal nightfalls
prestige nightfalls uh five of swords
called
no chant what we had the idea was then
we had the gm's
at this point i think the only way to
really
fix this or or or a major way to fix it
is to remove champions and start
start bringing in more enemies like the
light bearers mm-hmm
like that's exactly what i've been
proposing on this show for like four
months yeah i was like yeah we've been
preaching this
ability-based
many bosses
that make you play a certain style to
beat them
because the champion mods don't work
yeah you know i think i think if
anything that's a joke
the become legend version of the
campaign proved that you don't need
champions to make
encounters challenging and fun and it's
just like
i think sometimes
bungie confuses difficulty with fun
for sure you know yeah i mean master val
since we're in the middle of this we can
basically just breach this topic master
vow is the exact opposite of the
legendary which queen campaign
because the legendary which wing
campaign was
challenging to an extent i mean i made
it through it solo but it felt meaty and
you could probably even beef it up a
little bit more by leaving those
mechanics still there loosen high pop a
super you can still get just railed like
you see that void shield flying at you
there's not a lot that's going to happen
if it bounces your direction you're kind
of so pressing grenade can end your run
oh man
yeah when you get suppressed you're like
whoa
and then your mobility's down and all
like those were mechanics that felt
really threatening in the right moments
but you could tackle them if you wanted
to run up and shotgun them you could if
you wanted to play back with a sniper
you could you could build into your own
playstyle if you want to if you wanted
to run up with now a glaive let just 97
shield reduction and smack him around
with your glaive theoretically you could
do that too
but when you have champions in there and
maybe it's barrier and overload can't
use my glaive that's out now so you get
limited so much in that way and
did either of you guys try master val
no no absolutely not
can you do it on your own no no
no no
yeah it is filled with more champions
so screw that
here's my proposal either do more light
bearers
you know would be great you know what
they should do for for master raids is
they should take a page from eldon rings
book
and just make like a
an activity that you can queue into
where you're like you know becoming a
disciple of the darkness and you just
like load into raids as a hostile enemy
uh every once in a while like you know a
looking elevator
yeah an invader that's what they should
do that would be way harder that'd be
way harder than champions i do not know
about them
let's see what happens
coming in floating in the air with the
ac yeah just ac 130 just rain in hell
fire from above i think i'm getting shot
from about 40 meters up with that wall
yeah all right i want to talk about just
like the idea of adapt versus craftable
raid weapons but i kind of want to put a
pin in that until the end so let me get
see if we can get through some of the
perks uh opening shot has been
fairly nerfed on shotguns not gonna feel
nearly as potent snapshot sights is
going to be a little less snappy for
special weapons they're trying to make
sniper rifles not require that perk so
much
full choke is going to be
a little less of a narrowing of the
spread smoothbore is going to be a
little less of the widening of the
spread desperado is not going to fire as
fast but the pve penalty is removed
because they're trying to get a little
more
uh flexibility what weapons they can put
that on air assault is actually being
brought back and it's rebuilt which will
now grant plus 60 airborne effectiveness
when you're wounded
so
it's going to work the same way i have
the storm would work so if you are
wounded probably like lose your shield
for example when your screen goes red
you're going to be much more effective
in the air so in theory if you are one
of those who lean into that and that's
your like crutch then in the air you
pretty much get you that's one of those
moments where if you are hurt and you've
got stompies on that plus 60 almost
would counter it for you if you lean
into that play style
mulligan
still sucks i think i don't think it's
gonna matter
it says increased chance to return ammo
on a miss from 20 to 35 on primary
weapons unchanged on special heavy
nobody runs it it's not worth it on
primary for damn sure so no thank you
uh compulsive reloader got a little
snappier uh faster reload buff from 40
to 50 and the reload animation is about
five percent faster adagio shout out to
fallout's video that is no longer useful
slug shotguns were able to get a one
shot body kill with adagio they turned
that down for shotguns from 30 to 20 so
it won't do that
uh and then icarus grip has just been
updated for the new airborne
effectiveness that you've got plus 15
airborne for regular and adapt is plus
15 plus five handling
um also for weapons they kind of tell
you what's leaving in season 17 so for
iron banner included finality finite
impactor nightfalls comedian palindrome
is going away at the end of this season
trials shires wrath and messenger are
leaving in season 18
so season 18 is going to be your last
time to earn these p spawn sidearm
archons thunder nightfalls plug one and
hot head trials i have soul and summoner
so if you are looking at any of those as
weapons you want to grind for have
options of
those are your time windows to work on
getting those
and then for abilities we got some quick
changes before gambit labs which seems
like a joke
axiom bolts have a their base cooldown
increased from 91 seconds to
152 seconds so they got a minute
increased on their cooldown time
titan's barricade when you are using
bastion also had its
base time
bumped up by 30 seconds to match the
warlock rift offensive bulwark now
provides 60 less grenade energy in pvp
game modes pve is still unchanged
whisper of chains now provides 15
instead of 25 damage resistance when
you're near a crystal unchanged in pve
renewal graphs got shot in the face i'm
pretty sure
while equipped renewal grasp increased
the base cooldown of dustfield grenades
from 62 to 150
seconds
and the outgoing damage penalty applied
to player victims in renewal grasp is
reduced from 50 to 20 percent unchanged
on pve
any big shout outs in the abilities for
you guys besides most things got longer
cooldowns
yeah
uh i think it
it speaks to the fact that they're
trying to make abilities play less of a
role which has kind of been their
uh motto for
the past couple months maybe even longer
so
uh i don't know
i mean some of these i argue i would
argue aren't really good enough to
warrant having a longer cooldown
but uh
uh
go for it man you do you destiny i don't
know i don't have any strong opinions on
this one and i was like for me i would
just say axiom bolts you i do get chased
by those i feel like they're a little
spammy right now that one that one i
could not care less about i was like
yeah those suck and again the titan
power of the barricade they do want to
give you the overshield but making it a
longer cooldown seems like a fair
trade-off because especially if it
matches the rift that seems balanced
um also gives you a reason to make your
resilience possibility come back
because i never do that anytime it's
like oh make your class ability come
back i'm like what that barricade shield
i use like once per match yeah for sure
i definitely want to increase that
cooldown but uh
you know now that it gives you an
overshield i definitely use it more
often yes what about you mondo any any
standouts in there changes for your play
style
not really most of it
most of it's pvp
uh
you got against pvp bro
it's exactly what i do bro
you carrying me through trails
i'm not feeling right you want to yeah
yeah 100
uh
yeah no
the axiom bought one yeah
i'm that that that's okay but the rest
of it
question marks
yeah
yeah i'll just have to get in all of
these we just have to see exactly we
just have to see
how how they were
applied
yep
uh gambit labs is gonna be the moat
thief version so now if you have
multiple blockers you're not gonna be
draining moats instead
every second the invader is invading one
moat drains directly from the bank now i
love how that is a bullet point and yet
below it separately they say keep in
mind
invaders need to be near the bank in
order to drain most that is the first
time i've heard them say that about this
so instead of like invading and then
being like hide and go seek which is
what they say they don't want it to be
hide and go seek i really hope it says
you need to be near
the bank uh like on the game screen
somewhere otherwise nobody's gonna know
people invade and be like why aren't
they draining now granted yeah you could
go pop a bubble on their bank and be
really annoying i get that maybe a well
of radiance just to be ultra frustrating
to just be hard to kill
honestly i think people are just going
to be shooting rockets at the bank to
kill the guy and then go back to what
they were doing since everybody has
rockets now with heavy ammo so i don't
know if this is going to do that much
are you guys even going to touch gambit
labs next week i didn't touch it last
time nope
is that is that is the question gambit
labs or gambit
it's just either way it's no
that's fair then why do you need the
clarification if the answer is no matter
what isn't it travis come on that was
called i'll save her in the moment now
i agree with you 100 percent yeah that
sucks i will not play it
uh shout out a quick to necromancer zale
with another 10 super chat message for
bungie if you guys are listening um
don't hate us too much
they are for sure
can we please get more matching making
in events like nightfall and seasonal
activities i'm a solo player rarely ever
do i have a bad matchmaking experience
maybe low level raid raid would be tough
but i can tell you at this point
matchmaking 100 should be on the legend
difficulty anything at this point
because if it's matching the powerful
gear not even pinnacle not above
pinnacle the powerful gear cap
probably you need to be you probably
need to be close to the powerful gear
cap to do that one match made i would
say unless you just want to do it by
yourself and under leveled but if you're
within about 10 levels of like say 1550
for legend that should be match made i
feel like or at least have the option
to try i have an idea for the
matchmaking i've had this idea for a
while
you could match make you could put
matchmaking in destiny in a different
way right it's not quite matchmaking but
if you had like what you can do with
private matches but have it
for like social spaces where you could
select to join a social space
with people who are looking to read or
looking to do trials
and make fire teams that way instead of
just loading into the activity with five
other people
you could
somewhere you could create a fire team
i mean i think that i'm not sure how you
how that would work
technically
you know yeah i mean something
like even in something like world of
warcraft there are massive social spaces
but when you go to say search for a
dungeon it's still typically done
through a menu-based situation just to
like walk up and like tap somebody on
the shoulder in the tower and be like
hey do you want to go play
that's harder to do than having a
focused way to filter people into
wanting to do an activity so
i don't know if the social i fully agree
that matchmaking should be on for
certain activities or have an option at
least because as mike g said solar
players can't even complete the war
table
that's a frustrating thing for a lot of
people
um some people theoretically could go
through and do legend solo some people
won't be able to but if it's part of
your like
season activity the fact that yeah it's
a higher difficulty but it's not like
drastically changing the mechanics i
feel like they you know put a couple
warnings you need unstoppable you need
barrier you need whatever it is
but then honestly go ahead and
just make it match made i feel like
legend at this point is not a dramatic
change in difficulty it's not going to
be scary enough that matchmaking is
going to make it a horrible experience
maybe have a minimum level cap or
something like that but that's probably
about all i would say i don't want to
try and carry somebody who's like 1450
and through master through a legend
nightfall that doesn't sound fun but
outside of that that's pretty much my
only piece
and that is most of the twab so we
actually made it through a lot of it
right at about two hours so the last
thing that i want to talk to you guys
about is
uh the master raid but it's the idea of
what crafting has done to
the actual master raid and we've got
adept weapons
that can use adept mods
they are going to likely see two perks
in the third and fourth slot
and you get those you get a random
adept weapon seems like it's probably on
a knockout list so you'll probably get
each one once first
and you get it from the challenge that
week on master difficulty or
you can craft your weapons from the raid
by getting the set number of patterns
but you have the ability to go after
your basically perfect god roll you have
access to two enhanced perks
and in the event that something like
today happens where we have a massive
sandbox shift or perks change or
whatever it is if your favorite perk on
your god roll gets nerfed well now you
can go craft and switch it
so
the way i described that yeah sure i'm
leading the witness but adept weapons at
this point
feel and i'm saying this from multiple
people in the community feel very
pointless to go for like master vog
people said there wasn't a lot of
benefit to them in the first place
and again they're kind of stingy on
where you could get it but even on that
one if you were gonna go for fatebringer
you would at least farm for it but now
that we have craftable now that we have
enhanced perks
adepts really feel
like they're in a bad place the master
raid outside of doing the triumphs
feel like they are not worth your time
so i wanted to ask you guys is there
something you think that they could do
to adept weapons to make them worthwhile
or do you think
at this point
maybe it's something
that needs a complete rework revisit or
otherwise where you guys at on
the way things are sitting with these
master level
raid weapons dropping a depth that
hardly can match crafted in the first
place
if not even be as good
should probably pass this over to the
guy who does all of these activities
mondo what do you think
thank you uh
i haven't done masterpoke yet but
uh master uh
bow
yeah but you you you grind for a depth
uh i get a lot of the dips yeah i think
see
our problem with the craftable weapons
that the craftable perks especially in
the
enhanced kinda not worth it
you know
some of them anyway they just don't
improve
the perk enough
you know uh
the
explosive light perk
that everybody was going after haven't
even enhanced it it just increases the
projectile speed a little bit it doesn't
do anything to the damage
you know
i think they've started to do stuff
stuff with the depths and somebody who's
done master master vogue would probably
know that's better i'm not sure what
although you've got soul drinker on the
raid weapons right where you reload and
based on that you get health back yeah
they've started to do stuff like out and
adept weapons
right so the depth weapons from the
breed
if let's say for talking six next season
it's sniper for barriers
you get health back
for stunning that
you get health back and it refills
partially refills the magazine on
stunning a champion
so whereas i i believe that
i think it goes further than that i i
don't think adept weapons are
the end all and be all because of god
bros
but uh
if you're talking about debt weapons
from the breed
then i think just the raid weapon itself
probably is enough but i mean being able
to put a depth big ones on or something
like that that does vorpal
me boss and major speck all in one go
type thing
i don't know i just
haven't used them to read pulse rate was
awesome oh i love that
version i don't know if the adept
version would make it
you know a completely different weapon
to the normal apart from being able to
put a depth perk on
well the difference is when you take
insidious that you can craft i can get
say
enhanced rapid hit
and i could get enhanced rampage for
example so enhance rapid hit you can get
um
substantial boosts to stability and
reload speed and then rampage it
actually extends the duration
of rampage and then you could even go
into rampage spec or i could go
dragonfly and pick which spec i want to
do that's already enhanced so you've got
these enhanced traits and seeing the
enhanced there's reload plus four
there's an adept mod that's like reload
plus 10 the plus six not really a big
difference
when you have the option for some some
are
you know some adept mods are going to be
better but again is it worth trying to
put together a group at 1580 then try
and do the challenge which we already
talked about the challenges are all
tedious this time around because every
challenge makes you basically play worse
i talked about this with scara last
night
so you have to play in a way that is
less than optimal
to get the adept weapon to drop
and then you have to go through the
world of hopeful rng
to where you're like am i going to get a
god roll you could honestly get a good
barrel
and two god roll perks that you want and
maybe even the messer work but what if
you get the wrong magazine on that
insidious adept version
or i can go craft one that is a god roll
and it's got enhanced perks there's just
not a place
where am i right and correct am i
correct insane
that you actually have to find five of
those weapons first to be able to craft
it correct you do yeah so you've got to
solve the master read
offers a one-and-done as opposed to
farming for five of them in that may be
the only difference because not
everybody goes into the raid fight you
know we'll be lucky enough to get that
because there is a lot of players in
destiny
they either maybe hit the read what you
get to do at once or
don't even read at all
so in theory that is correct because yes
you could get lucky go into caretaker
and get an adept insidious that's a god
role on your first time doing it but
take into account the person you just
described the person who barely does a
raid in the first place probably not
going to do a master first
and if they are going to do master
they've already probably run the raid a
little while to get used to it gotten a
feel for it and if you're going to go
run master it's not going to be the
average casual be like hey can you drag
me through master
valve the disciple where i've got to do
a challenge where you got to do one
tedious thing every time on caretaker
the type of person who might be lucky
enough to do a raid is probably going to
do regular in the first place would be
my guess personally
so and it's also the fact that it's
already
so that's the like you could i can
answer that
because there's people in the chat
who've done exactly what you say people
don't do that beat the master read when
they hadn't actually beat the normal
because it was one checkpoint
and you know checkpoints are a thing
that's true that's fair
you know i'm i'm not saying that there's
i'm just saying that there's al there's
got to be a you know yeah there has to
be a plus and a minus on both sides you
know there has to be an argument for and
against i think there is a place for a
depth
but i think there's also a place for
crafting
i think it buys into the type of player
you are
do you have the ability to go and farm
for these weapons and build a good
weapon
i think sometimes some people have to
i don't want to say lump but
take you know i got my depth weapon i'm
fine the perks aren't great but i've got
an adept weapon which increases all the
stats and i can put the mod on and
you know
so i i
i don't really think it's a big deal
either way to be fair
yeah that's just my opinion
i i kind of think uh
adepts
aren't much better than uh craftable
weapons and they carry with it certain
risks and i think that that's okay i
think this is a situation where
destiny players are a little too close
to the game and don't realize that
uh
it's actually set up in a way that makes
sense so like if you're the average
destiny player you're probably not even
going to craft weapons just because even
that takes kind of a lot of effort you
have to
craft a raid weapon you have to get it
five times in you know a red frame state
which is already like
way way more than the average destiny
player plays so there's like this kind
of bottom tier of people who don't do
crafting at all and then there's a like
what i would say like the middle tier
the core like destiny player who maybe
is
is uh you know a regular player but not
super ultra hardcore has to do every
event not not the teddies of the world
right not the not the mondos um and
those people are probably going to use
crafting and they'll use it to get like
85 percent of the way to like
you know a top top top s tier like god
roll because
uh they can and it's also easier to
manage because as you said they can just
reroll the perks and that makes it that
makes the barrier of entry to having
like pretty good weapons
somewhat accessible i mean it's still
crazy that you would have to do a raid
five times but um it's still you know
somewhat in the ballpark of like if
you're a regular player you can get
there and then i view adept weapons as
being like just the upper upper upper
echelon and for those ones i feel like
you want to make them as inaccessible as
possible because one those are really
for the people who play destiny
constantly that have you know 7 000
hours on it and like just like doing
that sort of content and they need
things to chase that's part of why they
play and also it's sort of okay if those
hard-won
perks then get
you know debuffed and then they have to
roll use a farm for a different role
because
that's sort of why
you're chasing adept weapons anyway so i
feel like they should be better but not
that much better because if there's are
they actually so i guess here's my
question are they actually better
are adapted mods better than two
enhanced traits and the flexibility as
you just said if the sandbox shifts to
go grind for that whole again god roll
versus i have a crafted weapon that's 95
of the way there
and i can switch the mod because or i
can switch the trade because it is
crafted and that's the point where it's
like
my question
they're better without the flexibility
factor but i think that that's
okay because the flexibility isn't
that's for the casual audience i mean
the the
the people who are you know the super
elites are going to grind for the god
world regardless and some people like
that some people look at the crafting
and go oh that ruins what i like about
destiny which is grinding for that god
rule and so i think adept should be
better when you're just looking at like
one-to-one but crafting should be better
long-term because it's it's whole
purpose is to kind of give players like
myself frankly i'm like a player who
like i hate doing the same activities
over and over again it just it bores the
crap out of me so i don't want to have
to do a grandmaster nightfall you know
five times in a week just to to get a
god roll but crafting gives me a way to
sort of feel like i'm
in that zone of getting god rolls
without having to you know hate destiny
because i'm having to play it so much
and and grind for a certain role so i
think i think it is the the goal should
be adept weapons are better in the short
term if you get a god roll worse in the
long term because
uh
craftable weapons have a a better kind
of utility and more flexibility that
that i think is better for a casual
audience but i think that that's a
feature not a bug
and i don't think adept weapons should
be significantly better than craftable
weapons because then it makes that
content mandatory so people like me who
just skip grandmaster nightfalls because
we don't we don't get a kick out of it
all of a sudden feel like we have to if
we want to be competitive and crucible
or if we want to be part of the meta and
pve and i feel like that is a line where
you're going to make all your players
hate your game if they feel like they
have to get god roll adept weapons and
that becomes a problem so i kind of view
it as like
the way things are now is kind of
working i think they could do a little
tweak here there maybe a depth weapons
can be a little bit stronger but i don't
think that they should be infinitely
stronger and i don't think that they
should have the same flexibility as
craftable weapons because the chase is
kind of part of that sandbox for players
so i'm looking at it like
kind of seeing the beauty of the system
that they've created uh but i i get why
people feel like they're getting you
know slapped in the face when they grind
for an adept weapon and it's barely
stronger and then it it becomes not
relevant a season later i get why
they're saying that but what i would say
to those people is you chose this life
you are voluntarily doing this super
extra super optional piece of destiny
that you don't need to do um and so you
know that's sort of the risk that you
have when you do that that's sort of
what you're agreeing to i think so i
don't know i i kind of see it as not
really a problem personally
well maybe that's just one of those
where we're gonna just have a difference
of opinion i guess for me it's the point
of if you literally said that the adapt
weapon isn't in the long term gonna be
as good as the crafted weapon
but in theory
it could take me just as long to get the
adept weapon as the crafted weapon or
longer if my luck is bad you're limited
on the number of adept weapons you can
get through your account every week
unless you do want to cash in a bunch of
tokens but then you still got to earn
those back but then on the other side if
i'm unlucky and i get crap adapt crap
adapt crap adapt every time and then i
finally have crafted my god roll that
effort put into
trying to get the adept weapon was all
for naught because now i just made the
other one and i could have done that
exact same thing without going for the
adept
does that make sense or am i crazy
do you have anything
i can see what you're saying there and
and and with that i kind of
again i just i
the only thought i've got on craftable
reed
adept weapons versus
uh sorry craftable raid weapons versus
adept weapons which ones are better is
literally the points that would be made
the only thing that you can say is if
you craft the weapon
you can when the when we get
seven nine thousand word
twaps yeah you can adjust
your build or your weapon
to suit
if there's something that's going to be
really strong but but that's to say that
those perks are going to be part of that
being able to build that weapon because
they're limited in their perks right
but i agree that it's about it
adept weapons it's more for me
the reason why people go after a debt
weapons i believe is because you do get
that stat boost in every stat
do you could you if i gave you a blind
test and said here is the exact perks on
an insidious
one is adept well that has been
masterworked one is not but every other
piece of that gun is the same do you
think you could tell them apart and that
step boost is what two on each stat
uh pro
probably not
okay so then until you put the adept big
ones on and asked me sure
a depth big one this is one of the few
crotch crutch things that adept has is
the fact that it's major and some boss
back put together that is like one of
the few things that depth weapons have
that's like literally it
but then on the other side you could
have rampage last little longer adept
weapons can't have enhanced perks
do you think adept weapons should get
enhanced perks either of you guys yes
travis do you think they should get
enhanced perks as maybe a lucky chance
maybe again i think adept weapons should
be stronger in the short term i just
don't think that they should be much
stronger because my fear is that those
weapons are so good they feel mandatory
or they define the meta or you have
people saying oh no i don't want to do
trials run with you or oh no i don't
want to run the raid with you because
you don't have this adept weapon that's
got to enhance perks and that just is
going to alienate people i feel like
people who are in like the
let's call them casual hardcore where
they play destiny every week but they
don't like beat themselves up to get
every single triumph and every single
depth weapon i feel like those people
are vital to the ex to the um the
destiny community and that they need to
uh they need to feel like they can miss
out on adepts and it's not the end of
the world and so to that to that you
know end i would just say adept women
should be good but not much better and i
think right now they're kind of in that
spot if you disagree that they're just
like
not even better like that that crafting
weapons
is actually better in the short term
than getting a god roll depth weapon
then yeah maybe maybe uh maybe they need
a little bit of a buff but i'm just wary
of giving adept women's too much of a
buff because if they feel mandatory it's
really gonna suck it's going to suck for
the vast majority of players who don't
want to grind for depths and i'm one of
them by the way i i mean i have trials
of depth weapons just by my circumstance
because i play a lot of trials but i
don't have any
you know nightfall weapons i don't have
any raid adept weapons i just i don't go
for that content so um yeah i just
i i'm wary of it man i mean i i get what
you guys are saying i truly do and the
raid is unique because nightfalls
they're not craftable right now there's
not a craftable
hung jury or hothead or comedian or
whatever is coming through the nightfall
those are not craftable right now i
don't know if those theoretically ever
will be and that's where having the
adept gives the person to go after the
grand master my thought is
take the first raid encounter with the
totems
the challenge mode
with the unstoppable champions while i
know people have done it i get that
but
the
effort of getting the challenge mode
done to get the drop
doesn't feel like to me personally the
juice is worth the squeeze
now people probably have that encounter
good and that's fine but the groups that
are able to do the challenge mode on
master to get in a depth drop
even for their sake the fact that it's
rng
is i think what hurts there's not even
curated roles this time around it's not
like fatebringer has two perks on the
bottom when you get a time lost fate
bringer two are random and two are
what you would consider the god rule so
if you do actually complete that
challenge you've got a solid weapon base
it's just four perks that are random and
it's the rng nature of adept weapons
that i don't think are
enough personally because you could get
junk for just as long in regular and
master and i think the junk randomness
is what hurts
this specific raid adept weapon to me
the if we're talking about
effort versus reward
yes that's part of my issue with this
well if you're talking about that then
there is no argument
you can if you can get if you can go
through a normal read truth or a normal
word read relentlessly
you know three times a week
keep doing it get your red ball weapons
i think there's a chest that might give
you red balls or yeah you can give you a
chance to get symbols you can get a
guaranteed red bar yeah right so you can
you can predictably after two weeks if
you read on each character you can craft
what you know well that's saying you get
the same weapon right yeah you can
if that's what we're talking about which
is
a different thing from are they better
then i agree on if using that as the the
the template
then for the ease of getting it then
yeah yeah then then you have to agree i
don't think that that's the argument i
think that it should be abnormally hard
for a minor benefit i think that that's
how it should be but i think if you take
adept weapons across the board though
and if we're just talking about debt
weapons across the board
right if you're talking about the raid
i think it's
as you've said it is a little bit more
difficult to get
the adept weapon and then you want the
right rule
whereas if you do something like a gm on
a double
double reward week
you know i ran three yesterday and got
two snipers from each one all with
different perks and that i actually got
open and short snapshot no lucky you
oops nice well it is
for now don't know how good it's going
to be now but you know it's still
the reward was definitely worth the
effort you know
wasn't too never took me ages to do them
but you're going to the read
and the effort of doing challenge mode
to get one that or even two that might
might not be very good
then yeah i have to agree you you would
you would definitely go with the
crafting method and those circumstances
yeah it's it's just a weird it's kind of
brought this whole crafting idea where
some people are like this is the issues
with crafting that's autonomy say that
and this is like this is the issue of
master content i'm in this weird point
where i'm not entirely sure the juice is
worth a squeeze
some some of you guys think that
in my mind the adept weapons aren't
better because to me outside of adept
big ones which even is probably still
debatable two enhanced trace versus an
adept mod and like two on each stat to
me
doesn't even make the adept mod better
and in some cases quite a few you could
say the adept weapon is actually worse
than the craftable weapon that's i guess
my issue is the fact that enhanced
traits do not seem to be capable on
those and it just makes it to where and
again we'll wrap this up but it's just
it's a weird state right now so i will
be very curious if they take the
feedback because i know there's been
quite a bit in this
that
is the time value again doing the
difficult stuff should be worth
something
even if it is just incrementally better
theoretically right now it's
incrementally worse in certain
situations and that's where i think it's
just this weird state where we're at so
just the long term i think
yeah yeah that's the main disadvantage
and i think it probably should be
yep
so
that's what i mean that was again i
talked about that with scarole if you
guys want to see that chat i'm going to
post it up on saturday i wanted to talk
it out with you guys
cog is busy i would have loved to have
had his thoughts on this one we'll have
to kind of pick his brain next week
shout out to uh our guest next week by
the way got jarv coming in so we're
gonna keep uh another
guy from across the pond just keep the
european guests coming over so hopefully
they're all getting some sleep after the
show
um
but yeah we'll be checking out probably
guardian games preview during that one
and everything else but
it is and i'll have to pick their brain
on it too because it is i'm seeing this
a lot on twitter i will be very curious
where
all of this lands because when you go
through and put your effort into
these very difficult things
at some point it does feel like it needs
to be worth the effort for
more people or i think less people will
find a reason to do some of these things
especially now that crafting is giving
you an alternative before it wasn't
there and this was actually a way like
vog this was your like better perks
curated roles it was a much faster way
to go after a weapon theoretically now
that may not be the case which is why
it's interesting so i'll just be curious
where it settles
um but honestly mondo thank you for
joining us tonight i think this is where
we are going to wrap this thing up at
this point this is one of those times
where i want to say the floor is yours
where people can find you check out your
content what you'll be doing what they
can expect from you literally this is
the time to self-promote the living crap
out of yourself so go for it
i'm on youtube no
you are so good at this
yeah well i'm not really good at self
promoting
uh i'm
i'm mcgage you'll find me at youtube
uh
live bundle
and you can find me on twitter
at live mundo
very nice yes go please follow this guy
check out his guy check out his guides
live mondo on youtube and live mondo on
twitter please follow him get this man
some more subscribers if you guys listen
to this show subscribe to his channel
great content nice guy and he'll walk
your solo butt through some of the stuff
that i haven't even done in a while so
please check out his content very very
nice guy and very patient in a similar
way to walk you through complete
encounters
so please please support him and get him
some love on his channel i'd appreciate
that
travis what about you don't see each
other as competitors yeah
honestly
i mean
don't you guys kind of compete for the
same
the same viewers kind of
i mean in theory but also he does grand
masters and i haven't scratched those in
a while if i got into grand masters that
might be but even then different people
are gonna have different perspectives
they like different ways things are
explained i've heard that enough times
where people like i'll watch multiple
videos over one thing just to kind of
get an idea so i
know i was like there's about four or
five of us that all kind of do fight
maybe six that do all the same things i
don't see anybody as a competitor
same way that i wouldn't self-promote
because
you know people people that want to find
you will find you and they'll stay with
you yeah you know because
and i like to support
everybody
in what they do
you know i
the only person i'll ever compete with
is me
i don't compete with anyone else a bonus
does a lot of
cool content he does a lot of
explanation a lot of breakdowns stuff
like that i don't
really do anything like that but i
always i always watch to show some
support
because i support everybody that does
the type of stuff that i do
that's awesome that's a great mentality
to have
pretty communist of you but i accept it
um
that trail was run at the weekend by the
way travis
i'm down actually yeah well yeah who
knows if i i've i've not played a ton of
crucible this season just because oh the
excuses have already stalled but i'm
down
i'm down we'll get through it uh
actually i've got a friend i've got a
friend i've been going flawless with um
pretty regularly so if he's on this
weekend i'll get you in
i'd love that
for sure
uh cool yeah you can find uh me on
twitter at ty guy travis if you care
about my tweets um i also
have a bunch of content on ign.com
ibontas reminded me that i did do the
preview for outriders worldslayer so you
can see that live on ign.com or youtube
um i i've got the review for postal 4
upcoming review for truck to yomi
you can you know find all that on
ign.com
and then um
i also have a destiny raid guide weirdly
which is super late i don't know
why especially
eventually
i honestly want to do one of those at
least for regular as well just yeah
because i know certain parts especially
like exhibition
i'm
mine would probably take way too long to
put together so it'll be later than
yours but it's the idea of like showing
stuff from every encounter like the
stupid detailed way i would do mine yeah
i mean there's
i can tell you after having one of my
videos be later to the party than it's
ever been and get it exploding you never
know if it's going to be the thing that
hits and you guys are big enough that
pel it's probably going to be fine
yeah it'll probably be okay uh the
reason it's taking so long now i
finished the script and the footage and
all that it's just because i'm editing
the video myself which is the first time
i've done that since
college so uh yeah i'm gonna that's why
it's taking so long um
and uh yeah that that's it for me um you
can watch a show i do on on sundays
called bitcast uh that happens at uh 8
am pacific as well if you want to hear
me talk about general games industry
non-destiny specific stuff um other than
that
how about you e
uh yeah so playing a little destiny over
the weekend playing trying to get to the
end of elden ring um finish the fire
giant haven't touched the big goblet yet
so i'm i'm getting close millennia uh
melania
no molina if i'm saying it right
she's apparently bugged after the patch
where she will her crazy multiple hit
move even if it doesn't hit you heals
her right now
so i'm gonna back i'm gonna leave her
sitting out there until i basically
almost finished the game but i do want
to go through and work towards some of
the other progression stuff i'm fairly
i'm not close to the end but i'm like
i'm towards the latter part of it i do
want to kind of like at least put a pin
in it
i've got an i've looked up some of the
later boss areas to go i've looked up a
couple things
i honestly got to a point where i wanted
to like craft one of the like the
preserving boluses just for like crimson
rot and i had missed the book somewhere
and i was like i need to find this damn
book and it was some random vendor that
i had like walked by or didn't have
money at that moment it was just weird
stuff like that so i i checked off a
couple of things and then peeked ahead
to just have an idea
um
i'm canada
but yes um the outriders world slayer
preview i got on my channel as well so
that one is up i had fun in world slayer
or outriders for about 50 hours and then
we know the bugs and the inventories and
coghead is logging issues for a while
but at this point honestly they've done
a lot of quality life stuff looks like
this is going to add a nice little
in-game grind and there's a piece that
we don't even know about yet so i'm
still curious and i think in june
if it's about a month after a destiny
season launches will probably be a nice
place for that to launch if you're not
playing anything else i think it'll
actually come down in a very good spot
uh but again mondo thank you very much
for joining us it was a pleasure having
you tonight and i just wanted to say
thank you for
losing some sleep to chat with us over
here in the states because i know
it is late for you so i really really do
appreciate your time to go and run some
content after this
dude psychopath him and and then he's
still probably going to get up in two
hours as his kids start making i don't
know how you do it man you are
you are a legend you're a legend sir so
we thank you for your time for all of
you in chapter one you have been amazing
for having me absolutely immensely
um thank you for all the super chats the
likes if you enjoyed the show drop a
like on the show please again subscribe
follow like all of these people's
amazing content and for everybody in
here for this episode tonight on april
21st thank god i didn't get jury duty
uh we're wrapping this one up so have a
good one everybody and it has been
the last word